you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery
yeah yo we out chair what's good man
yeah thanks for got everything yeah
we'll be there
I got cameras and she needs I'm mostly
good we're all set up we're good we're
ready you like bring the true youtuber I
got cameras man we went on this whole
time ray but yeah that's the that's
pontus right there that's that static
pontus water that's that loud is there
louder louder this is a perk this is the
pure water pure that straight drop
Cambodian mount in the mountains of
Cambodia yeah this is a the Blue Ridge
Mountains of Georgia
you're actually the first to get the new
label I was accident we just we upgraded
our labels I remember the last one yeah
a lots a lots been changing you were on
here in 2016 yeah me yeah so a lot of
what I love I've been doing this more
lately to where I'm I'm interviewing
people like past guests on here yes to
see their progress and it's really cool
to see people predicting things that
have actually happened right right right
and you're one of those like I
interviewed Tyler Chronicles and he was
talking about all he was like he had a
specific goal list of like I want to
like be on this big tour I want my my
television show to get picked up for
another season he's in LA filming it
right now I got picked up for season two
like all these specific things he wanted
to happen are currently happening it's
kind of the same with you in our
interview in 2016 yeah you're doing a
lot of the same thing man yeah so uh I
said I got the fan base and then I set
up the tour you know well first of all
man I'm congratulations on you know I
wonder just the progress of the podcast
reciate you man you don't say cuz imma
like add the
every listener your ha brethren yeah
maybe something Monday I sweetie sweetie
sweetie I was but you see you put out a
statement you know they're so bad about
it because I know the hot brother verse
relies on that Monday at 8 a.m. and I
was like it's not right you you didn't
leave us hanging you let us know what
was going on so I record with respect
that 7:50 a.m. hey guys this is the
situation as soon as it just all of that
so it's gonna be aleca it's it's out
Monday the following ok so it'll be out
tomorrow as of us recording this but it
just had to be done you know and yeah so
sometimes you know you you got him when
you put there cuz that's a big episode
for you yeah you don't I mean so you
wanna make sure you got your ducks in a
row I understand it completely you know
I'm just so I was like I want to hear it
now right I want the boat podcast now
but I was like all right you know but
it's cool I understand that's a big
that's a big episode I figured you know
if it's Bo Burnham I was like people
wait a week I could wait a week I'm
going to make sure you got your stuff up
and right you want them yeah yeah yeah
so yeah so I want to make sure all the
ducks in a row all the infrastructure
levers place I respect it I'm from uh
from a hot brother and I appreciate that
but you know from being on the Internet
consistency is king like right on that
yeah they do and that's um some of the
things out uh well I've gotten better at
but for a minute I used to just go away
I just go away and come back but I've
got better at a narrow um cuz cuz it
like always say to like when someone can
consistently listen to some or they
consistently watch some it builds up a
different type of fan ISM like when I
set up the tour and I went on tour like
I would have people um like one lady may
drive 12 hours somebody may fly
overnight you know I did show in Atlanta
some people flew from Houston what the
yeah is crazy Lane like the famous yo it
shocked me man somebody flew from
another country in DC is shocked me man
I like I got raise my [ __ ] ticket
price where they fly from um I don't
know like he was trying to tell me but
his English wasn't the grower you see
told me he told me I can't his name I'll
top it was over here I got it on camera
he said it on camera but I can't like
name out top of my head he flew across
the pond
yeah baby right
ready so I'm using one them like thank
you by looking people you today like
this flossing my man's you know the
media so they got a tow you know this is
not a DC real fast and catch my best
mood yeah that's a whole other level and
in the first our first interview we
discussed that which I'll link in the
show notes for people to hear yeah one
of the things we discussed was the
difference between followers and a
following right you have a follow wing
but I built it that way man we were
talking about that you gotta be able to
follow me right yeah I may not have a
million followers you know me but I bet
I got like a strong so you can have a
million followers but then you're
following is very low but then you can
have you know a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand followers but you're
following is really strong look strong
as hell yeah yeah I think that's what I
built my following off that though but I
know I know what my core following is
and I double down on that and from there
it was like re you know that I was able
to sell out majority of the shows and I
did like I did eight I did like a a CD
right yeah I went to Chicago and with
new I tested it out cuz you know I never
had line before before that for the tour
I had never had love is so uh yeah I was
like I was wondering like if I could do
I knew I could do the time but I didn't
I never done in time straight I had
never done more than uh I say fifteen
minutes onstage straight before the
first time my hairline
what yeah but I go ahead in you doing 45
yeah but I had a room right in a late so
what I would do is I would break up so I
started doing like my set in six and
seven minute increments right between
each guess and I was like okay what L
was like 40
you know so I was like sauce it but I've
never done it all you know it's
different what you do all again you
gotta stretch oh yeah uh it's sorting I
did it for the first time I did in a
small crowd sick I took baby steps so I
didn't front like 50 people and then the
next show I went it's like 100 they
didn't show at the day I did like a
hundred twenty-five and fifty sauce I
just I kept I kept like like elevating
each right all right and because I gotta
figure out how to work a room and wonder
I had never even featured for anybody
the best thing that happened to me
before I went on tours I got a chance to
feature for luenell you know luenell oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so I got I
got a chance to feature for luenell and
I got to do like five shows and I got to
go like
thirty minutes big show like oh this is
great you know that mean you don't say
this is great so in front of her
audience yeah for the honey so wasn't
even my audience so right now I really
get to test it to make sure make sure
anything work before I got in a row and
it gave me confidence because that's the
thing is you performing in front of your
fans is one thing as opposed to
performing in front of strangers
yeah that's we whole other hustle that's
a not think you saw over happening just
for laughs oh so what you saying right
this is a great example of what you say
see when you you got I call it home
court advantage you're in front of your
fans yeah your people that's home court
advantage
you always give every shoot better at
home right but you gotta practice away
but a lot of the internet telling us
they never get a chance to play away
games so when they finally get to an
away game you know they're like what the
hell is this is a crowd you can't hear
that it's like it's like a college
football game with some weight they grab
one shut up its fourth then when you on
the goal line you trying to hike the
ball you can't get the count you're
looking at the coach like I came to the
count coach I can't get a count so you
gotta get your fingers and guess and
then get booed you're right so it's like
mechanist I feel I feel like that's what
happened to me uh did just laughs man
he's always work out always work out in
front of my crowd not for the Micra
always work out in front of a way crowd
like I go to let's go
yeah you know 80% white people I may
have one wiper you wanted to people that
I know me but you know to me like it's
mostly you know you know what's cool is
um or I go like do your room know I go
to like rooms like that where I feel
like no one knows me and I work out the
material yeah then I'll take it to my
crap because I know I say if it's funny
in front of people that don't know me
this could be extra hilarious in front
of in front of people that know me
because I got home court advantage so I
make sure I can shoot really good at a
way game and then I'll take you to the
home court before I go so I don't I'd
never take it to the home court first
you know I always look at it that way uh
that's how you know if it's truly if it
truly works horse they want the true
justice yeah they don't know you they
don't know yet but your people go be
excited to see you anyway they saw you
off the internet and I think that's what
happens with a lot of Internet
and I don't know the future for him you
know to me errant like dare night
someone who blew up on Facebook right
yeah yeah it is a southern mama so he
blew up like playing a southern woman I
guess and I'm not too familiar beyond
just his name and the he's a he's
selling out theaters yeah like thousand
Cedars yes crazy man out of the Just for
Laughs Superbowl of comedy in Canada
right and they're like what the stuff so
but that's that's what happens own but
even a lot of comics we're you know I've
been doing this over eight years and I'm
like I don't really have like you have a
fan base you have a home court advantage
you can draw how a lot of comics even
struggling with building a following so
how have you been able to build a
following as opposed to followers well
you got to figure out what you which
building the base around that's the
first thing and always say okay look
pick your weapons right and then once
see most comedians they have a problem
with perspectives you know like we could
and that's what we quote comedian
perspective we have perspective that's
our thing but they have no self
perspective right only then they can see
is their own perspective but they can't
look outside themselves and actually
look at themselves and see their weapons
as comedians we all have weapons right
so the first thing you got to do is line
your weapons up on the table you know
for instance if if if I'm fighting
somebody and he close up I wouldn't grab
a bazooka because he closed up you know
I would grab a handgun or a knife he
close up but if a rhino coming at me or
elephant coming at me I want the bazooka
right so you got to pick what weapon you
want you know what I mean just because
you may look at this guy he got a
bazooka that don't mean you can't win
with your pistol or you may start off
with a knife you may not have any
weapons you may have to start off with
your hands you know like you don't have
any weapons I got start off with my
hands they don't mean you can't win the
war and what I mean by weapons is like I
line it up on like right now if you will
look at your weapons what would you say
your weapons are on stage you know just
generous as as a comedian like right now
this podcast yeah this is a weapon this
is a weapon because it puts him in front
of other comedians and puts you in front
of people that could be game changes or
push them in front of people like me
that just love listening you know I'm
just gonna add the listener you know
what I'm saying and then you never know
what could happen somebody well y'all
know the perfect guy you know somebody
happened or or somebody made you start
some kind of network and I say I know
the perfect guy right
boom confirm this so this is the weapon
so you say this I don't know this your
greatest weapon I'm just giving you an
example is weapons totally yeah so
that's what I did like I built the I
looked at my weapons and I said what do
I know okay well I know black woman you
know I mean I dated a lot of black woman
so I started with this puppy character I
said I'm gonna take this puppy character
and I'm gonna take all the issues that
black women go through for my sister
from a grandma from the woman I date
from the guys they you know from the
guys today day and then I'm gonna put
the the heart of that inside of a puppy
and then I'm gonna get up up in life and
I'm gonna build my base around it so at
my shows
it's like 70% black woman but you know
the black woman got bring her friends
she got bring a boyfriend so I always
say if you can sell one ticket for every
one ticket sold you sell the extra 1.5
tickets and what I mean by that is like
if I do a venue in the venue host 200
people right I'm only gonna have 60 70
names on the paper I bought tickets but
they bought two or three you know you
know you gonna have something about one
yeah here and I'm saying so you're not
selling 200 so 200 people you selling
just 200 tickets to about 6070 people
got a look at it like that makes it more
realistic make it more realistic and you
got to think if if you you're doing the
tour and you got you know a hundred
people don't want to come see you at 200
hours where's mm I'll show now you able
to do that
two times a week that's four thousand a
week now you able to do that you know
every week now you're looking at you a
six-figure comedian just off the base of
all those those few people that want to
see you now in order to sell out a venue
of 100 people I said you gotta set up
right 42 40 30 40 different people so if
you can just say if I could just get 30
40 people to buy my tickets cuz they go
by 1.5 remember I told you to go by X
doing even if some people may not know
you but they friends they gonna bring
their friends or they got a brand new
boyfriend and they go brain like that
and that's how I look at it so I always
say I know sometimes we look at anybody
well I don't have millions anger better
sell out of show but you can't you know
but if your base if your core base is
strong you know a thousand people to
feed you thousand people uh you could be
able to survive off a thousand people
they go were merch to go in anything so
even he's setting up the merch right was
mean using a weapon so I say I got this
puppy what else can I do
what weapons do the puppy have now
I could use to get out there okay we do
these t-shirts we do this kind of
t-shirts we give our slogan it was like
that so I came into it thinking like
like five steps ahead like business was
right so we're not when I did it you
familiar with the puppet you know
talking about he sure yeah he's too real
Instagram is quisha to Rio Jones there's
some blood here
shameless plug so that's what I did man
is so uh I tried to be like four five
steps ahead and you know I mean and I
actually wrote a TV show off the puppy
so I came in thinking like how can I
transition you know to me because most
internet stuff can't most Internet
comedians can't translate the TV and
that's just here's what it is man they
not ain't no TV home talents you know it
ain't no not to him it's just that's
what it is so that's why every almost
every internet person that they tried to
push on TV has failed you know I mean
but what I did was I said okay let me
let me make something that's for TV and
then let me reverse engineer it and then
break it down and make it for the
Internet and so that way I build the
world around a puppet so that when I
take you to see via translate because
you can't take what their knight does
and put it on TV because there's no
world in around like what he's gonna be
southern mom for thirty minutes he can't
you know I mean because there's no world
around the souther mom but see I took
the puppy and I said just Keisha's world
right so you know like if somebody do
roast you can't build a TV show around a
roast they do theoretically it's not
sitcom you can't like what they go do
roast on a sitcom total world it means
the whole world and so with Kisha is
certain laws I don't I do not break in
the internet because like I'm always a
boyfriend now she may have other guys
she dated in the past it's try to call
that is or that but that's like
different character so as much as it is
the puppet is me playing like eight
characters in her world you know I'm
elated Hindu guy that's on the phone
yeah you know I've later the guy with
the beard I play the guy I play the
goddess locked up in jail ex-boyfriend I
play a boss like different people I play
a co-worker so it's like I build the
world around her so when I take you the
TV is easy to translate because if they
like the two-minute joints all I got to
do now is do six of them sketches and
write a little dialogue in between and
translate they already familiar with the
world uh you know I mean they already
familiar with there were and that's why
I believe in a translate verses that's
the I and this ain't me being arrogant
is no shaking I've been on the internet
since the beginning you've been
yeah yeah so I believe if I if I said
dumb myself down I get a million follows
if I attack and say I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do it like this uh-huh
but the longevity is when I plan for
because I've been here for a decade I'm
one of the original social media I guess
you'd call the social media guys social
me comedians or whatever your mom I've
been for a decade so I seen a lot come
and go I seen a lot of my peers I
started with they came they came and
they went you're not seen him getting
movies in Hollywood boom they came in
and when I seen him get a million
followers they came and they win I'm
still standing you know I mean I'm all I
caught another wave so I'm still
standing so that's how I always look at
it I'm like alright let me try to see a
future because I know a million
followers if the following that court
you could disappear tomorrow yes you
know every year in the Internet in my
pain is four years every internet years
four years I count every every every yet
so I counted every now every regular
year is for enternet years I said it
backwards so every that's how fast
internet moves in my opinion so every
regular year is for enternet years
that's why you see uh
we can go down a list the people that
that disappeared you know I was not on
the internet that just disappeared
you know at one point it was like
mentally limited mentally challenged
guys was like the welven race was the
wave your wave it was like yeah even
they was happier now this comes in now
it goes in and out you know but if you
got a core Basie you don't go with the
way so how do I control yeah so how do
comedians cuz you know a lot of
comedians listen to this so how what
advice do you have for comedians trying
to build their own following and create
their own way pick your weapons right
running your weapons and what I mean by
that like I said lay your weapons out on
the table and you could say okay what do
I do best what's my weakness
so if roastin H I ain't your best weapon
then don't don't get on there trying to
roast people you know what I mean you
know a lot of Khomeini's doing a side by
side thing that's what they do they
watch it and there goes you know I mean
that's a wave and it's not yeah it's a
waste away TV show that's not a TV show
that's a waving that will disappear yeah
you know what I mean that will disappear
you only as good as I say algorithm a
lot of social comedians are algorithm
built and they don't know it they hit an
algorithm by mistake
you're only as good as an algorithm yeah
Agron that's pushing you that's but when
you got forefather you gonna be as good
as you could be now see like yeah when I
say an algorithm that's pushing you like
a certain point certain social platforms
allow allow certain videos to get pushed
through it
you know what I'm saying and what I mean
by that is Facebook may say okay we like
these type of videos right now it may
let you push you on the front page you
too may say we like these videos now but
once their algorithm dies then you die
and then a lot of people like where
nobody [ __ ] with me no more another
algorithm my [ __ ] with you no more so
you're not in front of people you you
you weren't core-based built your
algorithm built you know that I mean
that's why a lot of guys disappear not
don't get it twisted you could be you
could become a hacker in the built and
then developer core base you know inside
the Agra the but yeah most of them are
just purely agar in the bill and they
don't realize that yet they didn't do
anything special
they were Jaguar in the build so if you
start them all over the day a lot of
times they can do and that's why they
fade because they can't do it again once
the hacker either no support them they
can't do it again they fade away what
how is you seen social media since day
one pretty much and in 2016 we talked
about the algorithm some when I
interviewed you where where's the
algorithm algorithm at I came and say it
that's how much I don't understand it
every so she never has all algorithms so
how you separate Twitter is just just
words not unless you uh um what do you
call uh when he when it goes all the way
down to order timeline get a timeline
what do you call it when he's gonna go
when he posts when you see yeah
no no main stars were to see uh the see
chronological quite a lots quarter yes
logical right yeah lots but everything
else has a gorilla so Instagram has an
algorithm Facebook has Agron YouTube ads
are algorithm you know I like when you
go on your phone and it tells you what
YouTube video you shall watch this is
just that's an algorithm but imagine if
you were hiding that algorithm and they
just pushed your videos to people yeah
how do you how do you hack these
algorithms well you know there's some
billion-dollar brains behind that like
right you guys look a hacker rhythm
light and then what I always do is I try
to do things as always positive so I
won't because it sometimes if you hack
the algorithm then a hacker and say oh
he trying to hack the hacker if you need
to kill you so sometimes the algorithm
to kill you it's like smart like that
smart like that you know what I mean so
you gotta almost you gotta cheat it is
line of I want to do everything Agra the
likes you know what I mean like if you
got communist how you got likes if you
got you got people sharing if you got
people coming from outside sources to
the video certain things to Agra them
likes but there's one thing that you
could say that does go remain consistent
on almost every algorithm
is gonna be watched I'm like how long
did you got Tim in a video how long
people stay on that video you don't I
mean do you keep them on a social
networking site so if I got a video
right think about this we got two videos
the same video you made a video I made
it
you got video X I got video right now
your video X you say um you say yo click
the link to my next video and it but
it's a you to see these YouTube videos
and it keeps them in YouTube but I say
click click the link below and it takes
from the Facebook now not at YouTube
everything gonna say they'll be like
Joel's orbit Ramos because he makes
mistake on Facebook so one of the things
that remains consistent because dude you
make people stay on the platform they
have her in the design and keep people
that keep people watching and keep you
in tree they don't want you to leave the
platform you know you ever been in the
YouTube dark hole oh yeah magically you
I had a hell did I get on alligators go
deep alligators be like yeah yeah yeah
like 3 a.m. yeah I was searching on how
to you know type some out it's fast too
yeah beeping they're fans man it's poor
Nate this program you know that means so
is like that so they like it when your
video they know that your video keeps me
blowing anybody boom we like this video
promoting promoting promoting that's how
I look at it ok so I would say eyes look
at him that's just act with the base but
there's your question as the comedian I
would say lay your weapons out on the
table see what you stronger like you
good let's let's take a look at
associate the guys from social media pop
you got DC on fly clearly he's good at
roasting right clearly he's good at
roast him right so that's what he does
you know so you may have one guy that's
good at sketches so he should do
sketches he may not be as good as
roasting but then you may have say ok
well I ain't really good at and no
social media but you know what I'm good
at talking to people live one-on-one you
you could have talking to people
one-on-one so this this is your episode
let me do this let me sit back into a
base let me do it see if I can build a
following off talking to people when I
went let me see if I can put myself in
front of people that could change my
career with the weapon I got or you good
on stage then you say ok well let me try
to get real good on stage to a stand-up
you know I mean if you know you ain't
good at stand-up but you're good at
improv what you're good at
you good at a theater you say let me try
to figure out a way to design a live
show ain't got to be stand up but if you
mean it could be just a live show where
I get people come in and we go over
these lines and we do this then that's
how you figure out how to make money
there's the one
thing as comedians we got to do is
survive so we're always thinking how can
I survive purely off of this right here
and if we sit back if we just look at
ourselves because sometimes it's hard
especially if you if you see my man over
here with his weapon he got a rifle and
he's shooting me and everything like
damn I wish I had a rifle but then the
rifle may not be the best for you you
may need the handgun you just don't know
that you better you better soon and good
ya know most of the time a sharp
shooting in the interview you've got a
sniper he ain't really shooting the
pistol that's what he do he his sniper
he got a rifle you know I mean but in a
sharpshooter he got a pistol you know if
I'm saying all this right I'm the guy in
the military maybe a military hey hey
man it's wrong man I was disagreeing so
different people got different weapons
you know it on stage some comedians are
good at act out others is good at really
sharp writing like it's a Chris Rock and
then there's like a Stephen Wright yeah
it could it's I think it's that self
awareness even on stage of like okay I'm
good at this Lebanese storytelling yes
story yeah that stories on gonna crowd
work Carlos Miller and Oakland say to
bet Carlos Miller's the king could be a
stupid [ __ ]
undefeated undefeated like he could say
anything that's do any if Lyla Yodas is
crazy I wish I could say stupid [ __ ]
like that yeah yeah it ain't a bad thing
but that's just like you ain't go get
him at uh heckling like if you heckle
him this that's what he got win that cuz
he he the King to that yeah you know me
but if you helpful a storyteller he may
not be able to hit you as fast as Carlos
would be you know but that's the
different weapons so even on stage you
got your different weapons on before I
mean that's what I had to learn to do
when I said to Tora and yeah make sure
you know I had to I had already found I
found my voice
see I didn't I didn't blow on the
internet fast I feel like I said haven't
blown on their net but this gave me time
to develop so unlike a daring night you
know you met me in the back of a comedy
club you didn't meet me off the internet
you know I mean I know this but they're
not you know I be oh then in a back of
the comedy clubs you know I mean I go to
any social media comedian that does
transition the stand-up so I had a
chance to slow develop so it wasn't
really a rush process for me yeah you
don't I mean
now did I think I was I was ready I look
at it now and say two years ago could I
have had one I probably say nah you know
I mean but I got ready I was happy to
aim below or I ain't get big on the
internet cuz I would've blew that way
you know what I mean that's the good
thing about having a vision I think is
two years ago when we're talking you're
saying okay my goal now is to build this
following and then build a tour around
it right it's why mood Atlanta together
boom I can't say why would you leave LA
coming to Len I said Lana is one of the
best stand-up C's in my opinion yes I
get to get up every other I get to get
up when I want no you got a room on
Wednesday a Laughing Skull guy Mondays
Tuesdays Wednesdays and did you get best
of Atlantis you know Thursday Thursday
every weekend yeah you can go to cats if
you want to go to Blair I can go
literally our whole white crowd I could
work out of the black room that don't
know you know y'all go to your room
where it's like a mixture of people so
it's like that it was like I was able to
work out the the sets and that's okay I
took these sets and then let me go back
to LA in my own room and then just see
if I can do them all in one night
hosting oh I can do them all in one
night I got see about two putting
together now yeah it's kind of like that
and I'm ready to go and that's what I
did is so by the time I got up to my
house on stage like some shows up here
on stage our intent she says are 15 so I
was like yo I got it you know what I
mean yes once I got that confidence I
was like all right cuz half a company is
just the companies being able to it
really is yeah that's where I'm at right
now in terms of headlining is it's been
my goal this year to headline more and
it's it's scary when you get out on that
tightrope and you're like alright I got
45 minutes to an hour and can I do this
once you do it a couple times you're
like oh cool okay I can hang in there
but then there's some shows where that
45 turns into 25 and you just shrink it
onstage sometimes we got away game
yes away game may not be that many
people there in a laughing stretching
your time yeah exactly
you're not improving off everybody being
happy knowing I realized that um always
wanting to sell always but what I do now
is when it happens I say like if I go to
the show and it's five people or is six
people or something like that instead of
doing the show or something like you got
to perform like it's to honey no you
know that in my opinion I perform like
it's six people in there but I don't
mean I give them a bad show I could look
at everybody talk talk you know that
mean anything I need to know in a room
for the 200 I can't I can't get to know
everybody roomful of 400 people I can't
get to know everybody I can't see
everybody right I could see six people
so I'm not gonna talk to them as though
I'm talking to 400 people I'm gonna talk
to them you you know I mean their net
that loosens up the whole
room now if it feels like units like one
of those little seminars you know they
bring you in the room and everybody
talking to each other they're getting to
know each other that good Dean that
stretches your time too and I feel like
they enjoy themselves a lot more so we
go down the list I just go down to when
I see look at everybody I go down to
listen we talking not going to my set
and then I'll try to like let them carry
me into my set sometimes cuz you know
somebody something and you know you got
a joke for that but it comes with like
once you don't a role you start
sharpening yourself up so every time
somebody say something you hate you I
got a joke for that so let's bring up
marriage oh I have five minutes of
marriage material right little improv it
looks now it looks improv yeah now it
looks a problem but it's important in
comics here that you're saying perform
I think performing in front of six as if
it's six hundred is like still perform
don't pile it on and be like man this
you only has six Roger up six hours yeah
like people do that though they do any
Joyce don't lose your uh your bravado
you know your bottle yes you don't keep
keep that but I mean well cuz you know
some people say perform in front of them
I just I'm just literally saying the way
you perform exactly change you know to
me yeah it's kind of like it's kind of
like like you said you you had a weight
gain move they blocking your shots now
or they or they double-team what you
gonna do now they double-team court
press ready full-court press you never
been pressed before now what you go dude
you still gotta win the basket still got
to go in the hoop so don't not put the
basket in the hoop but now you gotta go
a different way to put the basket and
you can't keep trying to shoot over two
guys they they for pressing you and a
double-team you across the half-court
now you got it you got to change you
have to change the way you attack it and
once you figure out how to attack that
situation now when it comes up in the
future
yeah it just becomes like an
overreaction yeah you don't already
press in a night I got so for that
exactly I got something for that you
know no no no never outta you but even
the performance side of a tour is one
thing but I want to get into the behind
the scenes of building a tour cuz I'm
actually in the works I am working
towards
recording an album and then going on
tour so building a tour is something I
would love and I think a lot of comics
you know I've gone on small tours
whereas like maybe a three year it's
like a three city run or whatnot with a
couple comedian friends when we were
like three years in not ready to be
performing
thirty minutes each yeah some shows
bombing you know some shows not paying
like they said they would all the things
you learn in the hard way sharing hotel
beds all that but that's the part of the
journey man yeah it is almost grown-up
store is what it was called almost
grownups brian de disco and devon
gaalan's
went on a tour and Ryan's Nissan Maxima
and it it was a it was an experience I'm
glad I did it but now I feel like I'm
ready to actually headline okay on a
tour of maybe you know I just got
proposed for something in Kentucky and
now I'm trying to build a run around it
yeah and even just like booking shows I
mean take us through the process of
actually building a tour okay now this
was one of the most challenging things
I've ever done right okay okay first I
went I went and met with the agency
right Oh kind of late so I was like I'm
gonna go ahead and throw myself into
that machine let them just book me the
shows and then meet me lined up but that
I met with him everything was cool when
I met with him I wanna make it like it
was bad but but I felt like then quite
understand what I was you know what I
mean like where's the puppet no no no
they were like what a puppet oh [ __ ] no
I mean okay so I look at myself as a I'm
not an Internet comedian but Dean I'm
somewhere in the middle of a hybrid like
an Internet comedian 'true stand up
because I actually came from true stand
up but Dean like I'm from the internet
so I'm like what you consider a 100% it
was very few true hybrids I feel like
there's walking around but I'm like
literally a true hybrid I've do internet
or I can go do stand-up on a regular
night you know what I'm saying
and so they gotta understand what I
wasn't felt like they understood it so I
was like [ __ ] I'm gonna do the whole
tour myself you know what I mean imma
said all that myself but then when I did
that I was like alright what I do you
know to me like I don't know what you
know that mean like okay I mean I meet
men in the club name me back what I do
when that don't happen you know I ain't
got direct was good I got to direct
contact um what I learned on the tour he
is right III bracele go now I did
everything first thing I did was I
collected emails from my people so when
I was doing my core following I
connected I collected the contact info
from social media from social media like
DM amore how you know know so I would go
here in my comment section or I will go
live and say yo I'm going
tor I saw a program now that I'm a
stand-up comedian I'm going on tour I'm
going on tour I'm going on tour if y'all
want to see me in your city yo let me
get your zip code right or let me get
you email your zip code now the reason I
got the zip code is because I know them
where they are so you hear them saying
so if I got five honey ml dresses in
Chicago remember all I gotta do is sell
40 people I got 500 they said they won't
see me do stand-up so boom my inner fire
honey they they buy the tickets it's so
I can sell like that Chicago show right
but then that's so that's how I got
that's not figured out how to get the
base there because there any moment the
algorithm can do what it could hide you
you see what I'm saying so you want to
have a direct contact to your people at
all cost so anything go wrong direct
contact so after I got a direct contact
to my people I went down the list and I
chose the cities that I mean okay I got
this mini contact Chicago I got this
mini in New York
this mini Atlanta this mini in
Birmingham Memphis you know d.c
Baltimore I said okay now let me set up
a run so then you see what's the what's
the most feasible so you look at the
venue's right so what I started with I
started to these lounge spots I do
company clubs too but I started like let
me because a lot of comedy clubs they
don't know you so he has to take the
book you mmm you know what I mean
so I was doing lounge spot and I say yo
is it a flat rate I can get you know at
the door so I look at him to be like now
this was the hardest name for me because
I didn't know what percentage to export
yeah that's hard for me to write and
nobody seems to [ __ ] know but you
know what it is the reason why they
don't know either they don't want to
share or I realized it first I thought
nobody want to share it when I was
accent Khomeini's but I say most
comedians I'm in this weird spot ain't
selling out no theatres but I'm able to
bring 200 people in right and so what
you have is this this is what I call the
beast inside a comedy and this is this
is this is um this is a need to know for
every comedian but it took me hours and
when I say hundreds of hours searching
for what I'm about to say now cuz nobody
seemed to know but I'm answer everything
money financial wise and this is some
people don't like to [ __ ] talk about but
it's something that should be talked
about most all comedians pressure you
got this thing where is comedy clubs
versus the comedian alright and the
comedy club trying to get as much money
out of you
they can test a job day in the business
they don't give a damn about you as a
comedian ain't no personal they job is
they make more money business this
business right so if let's say you got a
venue right you got Joel's comedy club
right and you say alright Remo I'll let
you do the club it's gonna be 50/50 I
said it now I can't do that I can't I
can't give you 50/50 now if you don't
know no better you'll be like alright
cool I'm gonna make two thousand a night
I'm gonna give you a thousand tremo and
then I keep it out and you buy fifty
fifty you mean I do get half the door
thank you Hannigan you have to the door
right so you may say all right they get
half the door you get half the door but
then anything that ain't cool because
they got liquor in the fool exactly
don't ever be fool about it a comedy
club is not a comedy club what 90% of
comedy clubs are restaurants with a
stage that's what Gary Abdo told me yes
owner of town and up title comedy
there's a restaurant with a stage
alright so if you bring the people in
the restaurant they making all the money
off the restaurant you don't I mean they
only no money off the stage to beat the
be to be frank with you you want a honey
percent in the door okay don't start off
better honey so when you asked if I'm
gonna start off with a hundred literally
cuz they go you know what they gonna
start off at 50 50 they go start off at
sixty forty they not gonna start off
with what's right and say you know way I
don't know you give me 85 fifteen give
me 80 you got talking down don't walk
out of there with no less than 75% at
door stand on it okay and even in try to
get a hundred percent in the door put
the claws in there and say you know
where I give you 75 percent if I sell
out I get 90 percent you don't mean put
the claws put a tear in there and that's
what a lot of commedia was hard for me
to find it was like it was like not me
to show first go-round you know the
first go-round company clubs usually get
you the first go-around you know it's
just something you got deal you gotta
get right the first go-around no I don't
know the [ __ ] I don't almost fell for
that I was like listen if you tell me
it's a guy down that alley that's raping
people why the [ __ ] what I walk down the
aisle
mmm-hmm if you tell them it's a guy down
the alley that's right people why would
I walk down the alley knowing that you
just got written I'll say how you know
well I got raped when I went down there
so why would I walk down there without a
weapon I'm a walk now never let me get
this gun real fast yeah is he raping me
I was your weapon the following yeah my
weapon to follow or the fact that I can
go somewhere else
uh you know I mean okay well you don't
want to make you don't want to make see
most comedy clubs are hurting that's why
I try get you on the wins there Thursday
you look at Jess hilarious she don't
Tuesdays Wednesdays Mondays Thursday
because she able to pack out a comedy
club that's great for the Cotton Club as
well she able to pack out a full-blown
phone and sees it on a Tuesday that's
not really on hurry up
so the comedy club winning on a Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday then they let
the comedian headliner come in on the
weekend and then they sell out again so
they love her cuz they like yeah we
weren't able to get nobody in here on
Monday Tuesday Wednesday no way go to
comedy club on a Wednesday you tell me
I'm gonna punch line on Wednesday tell
my people you see so if I say yo look
this ain't me on Wednesday Timothy but
you see right you know what I mean so
it's very few comedy club seconds that
can solely Packer being you about just
based off their name you know what I
mean so tell my people you see so if I
going down a Thursday and I know you've
got 30 people here I know you got 30
people and I say you know I'm bring 200
people here you're not giving me 5050
that's we ain't doing that
if that's what you want to do and I go
over here mmm I got got found a lounge
spot you know think about it Joe you say
all right Remo let's have a party at
your house man and I say all right cool
I say all right job we gonna split
everything 50/50 but I'm gonna keep all
I'm gonna say all nachos or hot dogs at
the party I'm not giving you no money
they're not so but is the guest people
got about two two items they got about
two nachos two things are not so good
and I got about two things about a water
from you I'm not giving you no money
dojo right you go split it 50/50 so huh
so boom you go
suppose we had 200 tickets me so each
ticket for ten dollars right there's
$2,000 so I see our Jovi splitting
fifty-fifty so you get a thousand I get
a thousand but I'm selling my drinks for
$10 a pop him some of my nachos would
tell us a pop so we got 200 people in
there we know they got about two of them
right so you got you got $20 they got
bout $20 with the items and it's 200 of
them so that's $4,000 so you got $1,000
and I got $1,000 off the door and I get
$4,000 plus $2,000 so now I get $5,000
you got $1,000 sitting in tonight does
this sound right no they don't sound
right at all right because you brought
the people in there and as all your
people is all your family your friends
your fans coming in here buying these
nachos there ain't none of this it ain't
none I don't I didn't do nothing to get
none these people in here two bodies
does that sound right so then why would
you let the comedy club do it to you if
they had the leverage you have if you
have a following you know how to
leverage that's just which
Modelling yeah you do so check it out
right like me I was like exactly so it's
two types right and we got that leverage
right there right you could do that when
you got a leverage if you could take
your father when you move them to any
venue you want yeah not a comedy club
may had a leverage like laughs is gone
let's go pack out you know it's usually
packed out regardless who planning
should I give you a flat rate you don't
get a door deal in you get a flat rate
you know some coming clubs say we go get
you $3,000 to do this weekend you could
do a Thursday or Friday a Saturday you
know and that's that that's that flat
based rate which is good because if you
ain't showing your following that's what
you got to break into you gotta break
into that circular taking a flat rate I
was somewhere in the middle that it was
hard for me to take a flat rate you know
I mean a lot of committing a comedy club
website you say how the hell is this guy
gonna booked at the comedy club you know
I mean no disrespect to that guy but he
ain't got no huge following like how was
he getting booked over it like over the
other guy so over me over somebody else
what makes him special to get booked
well he most likely he would agency or
management company and that agent call
up and say he had developed me act to
that agent right so I managed might if I
manage my kelps and I manage the
comedian with 2,000 followers right now
what my camps come through the comedy
club he gonna make $100,000
no he gonna sell out eight shows but I
come to Club F $40 pop and they all of
them go pack out yeah so you say you
know what I'm gonna give you my kelps
but you got get is a developmental act a
weekend you see what I'm saying cuz they
signed to the same agency you hear what
I'm saying so I'm just using my Kevin
exam of course you know same common
structure common structure so they
signed to the same agency so they're
able to get in the door based off they
agent you getting them saying they stop
they agent and then the club don't mind
it because some of these clubs got
enough pool where they say you know what
they do the UH
they do the UH they fish ball tickets
cuz it's a restaurant so they just try
and get people in there so they say the
Atlanta comic day they may say okay we
got these free tickets to the show and
giving out man free tickets come to the
show free tickets free tickets free
tickets your birthday you go to start on
the new birthday tickets some clubs
taper the room paper the room right and
so you may see 300 people in there or a
comedian say man I sold out the joint
we're not a comedy club gave away enough
joints you sellout you saw a 50 tickets
and I gave 150 tickets right because
they really just want the restaurant to
be filled up your honor I mean so they
can make money
the restaurant and then you just so
happened to be there you talking a lot
of people he may fool it's all they want
it's to feel that fill it up they want
you to be good I want to go I didn't
want you to be good because always the
better show is better for the restaurant
it's to act as good people come at and
so that's how they do and you got to
think if you're a comedy club you got a
hundred thousand contacts got a hundred
thousand contacts and you got all their
birthdays it's easy for you to fill the
room because you can reach out to you
know you could reach out to ten thousand
people on any given weekend and say boom
birthday tickets right pack it up a free
tickets and so that's how a lot of
comedians get in here and that's why
they get that flat rate but I can take a
flat rate I was in a weird place where
financially I don't think it'd be wise
to me to take a flat rate
you got think now that if you say if I'm
doing the weekend right and they say all
right remote will give you $25 a weekend
we'll get you a fifteen hundred dollar
bonus for every show you able to sell
out what this comp tickets or your or
just show up sold tickets so then so
even if it's even if the room pack out
on free tickets they still give me a bit
C hundred all the bonus you get I'm
saying but you got to think so if I do
five shows with that - honey I got they
let's say that's his flat rate they pay
me two thousand dollars to do photo
shows right they say we want you to do
two on Friday - on Saturday we go get
you two thousand dollars okay and for
every one you sell out people you $1,000
bonus so if I'm able to pack out faux
shows I get the two thousand dollars
plus the four thousand so that's six
thousand dollars right now I can make
now what if that room holds 300 people
right and I'm able to sell out every
show at $300 I mean I maybe sell out all
300 seats at $20 a ticket
so that's $6,000 a show so I did faux
shows so you do six you do you do 6,000
times the folk that's $24,000 but they
gave me 6,000 so that's see if I'm able
to sell it out so I didn't but I don't
know so you know I'm saying so if I sell
out of room to the max and guy love me
god is good yeah I mean I made the
company Club $24,000 and they only gave
me $6,000 that mean I took away that's a
good damn 2080 split my way I can't do
that yeah you know I can't do that but I
don't know I'm in a weird spot where I
don't know what they go cook you know to
me so I could take a flat like I can't
take a flat because what if I do these
bow shows and they all sell out
you go get all the money give me six
thousand dollars even though that's good
for four shows but it ain't financially
that naturally is good cuz usually I was
six thousand dollars dude what makes six
thousand dollar two days that's great
but I could have made twenty four
thousand dollars mm-hmm you know I've
seen and a lot of your shows on this
tour were they at you did Gotham comedy
club in New York or were they all comedy
clubs and were somewhere no dependent
venues because that's almost a whole
other negotiation when you're
approaching like an independent venue
all right so I just did an indie well
I'm trying to book an indie venue in
Philadelphia right no it was like okay
we give it to you for $2,000 and like I
can say so you rent it from them for in
2000 no I'm not do it for 2,000 well
first of all to thousands out it only
holds 90 people
uh-huh I'm like yo if my tickets $20 a
pop I'm sorry they tried to charge me
$50 right just to hold the venue just
all the venue okay but my take is $20
and it only holds 100 people if I sell
out on the May 2000 I'll make $2,000 but
the venue cost me 1,500 hours 500 500
hell is going to be later fine I say but
you got a restaurant I mean you got food
and liquor so I'm not to pack your
restaurant out you know and I can't do
that can give you $15 and pack your
restaurant out and then you keep all
that a restaurant and you keep odd
liquor you know don't work like that
you know the Miss Martin that ain't
getting great you know to me I ain't
gonna come comedic Lee right that's what
I call it financially right so when they
coming to Indy joints you just got a
it's kind of like you got a bargain your
way down you got to say look man I'm
able to pack this place but see it's
different you got to look at do they do
they have food and drinks okay I don't
mean do they have food and drinks it's
totally different than got food and
drinks so you can't come in talking to
someone who has a restaurant who doesn't
have a restaurant like they have a
restaurant cuz you gotta understand they
may need 50 50 because that's the only
way that they go make a profit because
they're not selling over liquor or they
not selling no food you get them saying
so they need more than the average
comedy club you know because they they
not selling anything so when it comes to
him I'm on my tour I did a lot of
company clubs some of the company clubs
ain't taking no less than 75 then that's
pushing it % percent of the door or the
door that's really pushing you aimed on
your first go-around you may not know
them like that so you gotta build up a
trust with them so you may say you know
where I'm gonna take the same fire
I'm gonna come back and exponent 90 once
I sell out we went on the second go run
so that's how I would do it but it was
so it was so damn hard for me to get
this advice from comedians yes I don't
know they didn't want to give it up or
they just were oblivious to it yeah
you're on I mean but that's what I'm
saying on the podcast now cuz I was like
yo somebody got it you know I mean like
what how does it how does the business
work so we train to be funny all day but
we're not trying to make money exactly
and I'm really trying to get trained you
can say so what shoot once you get into
this once you get into the uh okay what
you get to the point well funny and I
should be able to make a living off this
yes you say I need to make some money
but you say okay I do can I make how can
I make some money now you know what I'm
saying but then you got to go through a
whole nother stage of getting like they
say you usually get raped on your first
go-around
what if you got rate why would I get
ready saying you there's another way he
said another way but what if somebody
like me who doesn't I don't really have
leverage at all I mean I just had
someone hit me up on Instagram talking
about how much they like the podcast and
my like and watching my stand-up and
they're like we want to book you
here in Kentucky and I was like oh
interesting maybe there's a way to try
to make a run how are you okay sewing
that so nice stage I got you so if you
don't have a pair tremo oh I don't I
don't I don't never look at myself is up
here but from the business side you have
way more leverage inside yeah do and
that's why what about yeah I was like I
put myself in your shoes you're not I'm
saying you got to remember um when you
hitting up comedy clubs you email the
company close trying to get booked that
it's a lot of a lot of comedians I say
them I mean people email a comedy clubs
mm-hmm yeah I'm saying so you may not
you may get lost in the sauce because
even I get lost in the sauce sometimes
trying to contact when I say lost and
sauce I mean you know I'm saying like
they they lose me in the hundred emails
they got as week so and you're you
wrapped are you not rep nah my hat I'm
on rep - you're not I'm saying so we I'm
out here repping for the unwrap you know
that's why I see since you bad I feel
like is essential for me to prosper
because I got to show people that you
can make you can make a run unwrapped
it's inspiring you know I mean you can
make you can make six figures I'm rep
you can make a million dollars I'm
wrapped
you ain't gotta have representation and
make it make a million dollars I don't I
don't believe that and sometimes when
you have representation when you a
Hollywood you got
but people see you on TV you don't make
that much money as you do solo dolo on
tour you make 25 you make a quarter for
every dollar you make Hollywood you know
you make a quarter because I'm gonna
break it down and you suppose I do
something and they pay me $100,000 right
they say we go get you ten episodes
$10,000 episode hundred thousand dollars
okay well my agent got to get 10% so
boom that's what we got nine thousand
dollars right cuz you get to gross my
manager got to get ten percent so now
we're down to eight thousand dollars
write your business lawyer you got to
get five percent you got to add him
because he's trying to protect you from
everybody trying to rape you right you
know what I mean he got to read every
contract to make sure and he sometimes
he push and get you higher get you more
money with your business like right he
get 5% off after after gross so not you
down at 75,000 right but boom Uncle Sam
he want 40% so take forty forty thousand
dollars off that's 85 thousand you said
I'm saying not you down to thirty
thousand so you man made $100,000 from
ten episodes but when it's all over you
made ten bout I mean you made $30,000
you down to about $30,000 $35,000 you
sent him saying and you live in LA so
you just you just grossed $100,000 real
quick but LA you know prices here in LA
you gonna rain you twirl honey and
that's for some something that the
shitty yeah you know navi and you leave
a solo less you got roommates but you
you on TV so now you're on TV and you
make 30,000 35,000 dollars at the end of
the year you don't understand but you
grossed 100,000 but you could say you
know what I'm on tour and I'm able to
put 200 people in this in this venue
right here two times a week and my
tickets 20 dollars so that mean I make
$4,000 a week so you times that before
you say I make $16,000 a money no
merchants on that so you said I make
$16,000 just off tour now you including
the merchants that you sell on to her
you include an emerge that you sell
online so you say I make $16,000 right
here okay well and the next one I'll
make another 16,000 so I made $32,000
right here so that 32,000 them two
months they're greater than their whole
TV don't know TV run you just did you
know a lot of times convenience fight to
get on TV only to realize that you know
it ain't what I'm trying to say it ain't
on TV ain't a gimmick but unless you
like you get into
that that uh that there will your your
show picked up you know I mean where
it's really picked up your on the second
third season then you go actually see
some money that you could pocket and
feel like securely good about if that
ain't the case then you will be fighting
to get on a TV show every year because
chances are they not gonna read your
script chances are your pilot not gonna
get picked up and if your pilot do get
picked up chances are it's not go green
Lynn if you do get greenlit chances are
it's not gonna make it past six Episode
do make it past six Episode chance does
not gonna make it past one season if you
do make it past one season chance does
not gonna make it past thirty season
they do make it past thirty sees chances
are they go cancel it before it gets
syndicated so you can always be in a
search exactly go more and more and more
and more and that's why you may see a
guy that had a TV show and then not he
drive down here and you don't see him in
that machine no more cuz Hollywood ain't
messing with him like that but if you
got a core base like Russell Peters you
don't need nothing yes
he rich he wanted to Richie on the
forces every year yeah you know one last
time you cut on TV seen Russell Peters
on there and he was all rusty Peters and
his dope ass movie Russell Peters in
this but he had a core base you know I
mean and at that moment YouTube was his
greatest weapon by accident somebody
like he say some I uploaded my stuff to
you to everybody need a hero you know so
his race needed a comedian at the time
you know weren't really his race
one-to-one no guy represent for the
brown people right at that time all know
that's offensive on the brown people
offensive by the window you're brown
right eyebrow but I can't say okay what
about you represent for the brown people
he came to represent for them and so
everybody need to hear also his core
following base we know we go to shows
what it's gonna look like so maybe don't
go on tour until you have like a reason
to don't just try to muscle yourself
onto a tour cuz now it sounds like I'm
trying to just go on tour for no reason
maybe I just up that maybe wait until I
have like leverage in game check it out
I'll say you got a extra set that
because you could get on these flat
ratios look somebody a club owner could
really like you then they throw you what
you get okay we go get you this amount
to come through on Wednesday Thursday
and Friday
because what they doing is they like you
stand up you don't I mean they like you
as a person like I think Joe Joe has a
lot of potential and so their brain you
in so never never don't I know you say
muscle your way still keep trying to set
up summer run keep reach out to comedy
clubs never stop doing that cuz only
takes one to let you in the door and
this guy right here can let you in the
door - because they all they all
connected with each other right
they all connected they know each other
on the when you're going - right that's
why you see a chameleon do Atlanta
Birmingham Huntsville Nashville right
the same [ __ ] run the same run as
Marcy Bruce my man is in Nashville and
then you know I mean it's the hunt
ability my man's in that's yeah it's the
same run they all know each other and I
named me Tony this is just a run did
they do Dickie they get people to come
like yo he sold out he did good here he
I really enjoy his show but come here
you're not I mean that could go for any
little region that you do okay any
little region that you do but I can
never tell somebody what path to take
that's that's up to them you know I'm
not you know you because you don't know
even me as much as you see me I made you
say okay I'm like right now I'm in the
process of setting up another tour but I
don't know but I don't know I don't know
you did one no idea window successful
now I got a running back because you
thought you sold out most of those shows
yeah yeah I sold out probably like I
didn't take a hill on any show so like
if I didn't sell out it was like a shot
and that's because it's a Wednesday
night and I'm in the middle in DC at 7
o'clock and traffic is is gridlock in DC
one of you have been his heart like
Atlanta's gridlock but DC is on another
yes another level man it's some like you
know if I did win on Saturday probably
woulda it would've cuz every show I did
on the weekends all that but I let me
know book him on the weekends yeah and
learn from all your past experiences
what's a part of the paperwork side you
kind of referred to the contract and all
that what all is outlined in the
contract what you mean the contract all
the weight well it sounds like you
reference that there's a clause and
things though yeah that's if you took in
a flat rate see with me I'm doing this
straight out right so you put it all in
writing
yeah I'm assuming you need name to be a
contract a contract basically says that
we all agree to what state right so I
can send you an email with everything
stated and then you could respond to the
email yes I agree to all this that's the
contract oh that works as good as like a
PDF yeah never works as good as a PDF
silence the contract is details mostly
what was about so a country I really
stated that what we state it personally
verbally let's put it down on paper so
they make sense but anything could be it
could be a country even the email could
be a country so you ain't necessarily
got I still set up paperwork with the
venues so but if my man's design
paperwork any matter no way I had to all
the money up front anyway you get paid
up front
see ya but when you do a flat rate you
don't get paid up front do they pay you
at the end of the weekend they've called
you an office and they say and they tell
you how many so how many company cuz you
so how much of food was they didn't give
you free food and then they write you a
check - all you let the Duchess yeah I'm
saying they pay for your hotel they pay
for your travel all that but see I ain't
get home or none of that
I don't you pay for motel what you pay
for my travel I want you to pay for
nothing I go in the comedy club I paid a
comedy club
so most of time when I get there I say
alright this how much I sold here's your
20% here's a check
I give me a check for a 20% I don't want
no fool I don't know axel for two
bottled waters if I'm my feature act I
do the same thing I cleaned up when I
leave you know I always say you leave
the club saying we got to have him back
mmm your and I'm saying every time I
left the club they always say you owe me
let me know when you're coming back
they'll they'll bump on my [ __ ] for
you a word did they love you he sold out
and give us no problems
he ain't drink up three hours with the
liquor he axes for no rider he came he
paid us he did his show and he left so I
thought let me get a Saturday but I
ain't got that setting let me see if I
can bump it for you you see what I'm
saying cuz they know that they go get
paid and they always say you like I
trade more do business so every venue I
left I kept everything and that's how I
keep I keep it I don't say strictly
business I keep my business strictly
nice like I do everything I say I'm
gonna do you know I mean so if there's
no headache all right they got a check
cut if I say you know where I'm gonna
pay you this amount of time for the
venue boom upfront or you want me to
wait and said I'll get that new check
that's cool boom I give him the check I
ain't cost no money it cost me no
headache I did my time we get out of
there I don't go over the light you know
show start when it's supposed to start
if he can't start maybe ten minutes I'll
tell them your can we worry about two
more minutes people still coming and
they say sure just give you a good
employee yeah be respected be respectful
professional and paid him most
importantly get him they bring the way
he's supposed to give them their brand
and everything else go come to ease and
so that's what I did and so always do
that if you if you a comedian they give
you a flat rate tip tip the waitresses
yeah they're giving you free food they
comedy club giving you free food and
ain't nothing you've been working a
weekend you call the waiter over there
and say yo if it's five people that work
there and you just made $35 that we can
and it's five people that work there
good morrow Ellis son honey Allah's got
your 35 honey but guess what's gonna
happen I guarantee now forget your name
mm-hmm I guarantee you they remember
Joel Oh Joe Joe Joe get was 20 oz pop he
called everybody over here say how y'all
doing you're having a good night
we're here listen this is 24 you 23 24
you 24 you and they go remember your
name and guess what when they when the
when the manager he may not beat it at
night or somebody even they dare and
they asked the employees how I was
trained more oh we love em oh we love
him booked him back but come back we
love em Oh everybody loved you so why
not just go to the same venues you're
trying to build another tour why not
just do the same no some of the same
venues but but some I'm gonna do some of
the same being used right but then I got
to go different places just so I'm ahead
pick these cities you look at your email
where I have the most people is where
you where I had almost a target yeah and
in Facebook I'll let you look at your
demo your demographics analytics too but
I also got I got the zip codes everybody
and so I run a zip code through a
program that lets me know a city a city
and state then what program is that it's
a program or an excel just be a
programming skill set
oh that's a weapon that's a weapon right
well we talk about weapons right so you
know your weapons how can I get my
weapons how can I get my weapons back
you see what I'm saying when I always
says when you leave the company club get
get contact information or everybody
they bought a ticket ooh
okay because that show the company club
got why you can't how do you you collect
it from them or the house report the
color club gives it to ya when you got a
little leverage I gotta say when you got
a little leverage but I think that
should be a given so yo I'm gonna do the
show but I need to print out but see
that's if they selling the tickets if
they sell the tickets say I'm gonna do
it but I need to print out every person
who bought it bought a ticket because
then you could come back around and say
yo y'all I'm being mad you can email me
something back in town yo or you give
them a discount you go 20% off y'all
bought tickets before
treat your people nice I called my I
call my people when I say people that's
the people that support me the people
I'll call them or somebody I had a video
uh during Christmas this grad Sweden was
like man I wish I coulda got my mom
opened up her quiches to our tray mo
t-shirt so it's Christmas sweaters and I
say you know what
ah damn they say yo he got her number
call me I'm gonna call you I'm gonna
call your mom it so that way she could
talk to me you know what I mean
huh Christmas you know that mean what
may honey so I called my people did they
buy a shirt for me or I ran out of that
sighs my damn iover so let me call them
real quick about yo wassup Karen what's
going on who is this this frame oh this
ain't rainbow this mean it's me I'll do
it that's how they end with AME so so
you think well now I come in a CD rain
coming you see enough yeah cuz I reach
out and touch my people so I look at it
like that
you know of me I text my people so tell
y'all what you you know what I mean like
I you everybody gonna be here so like I
like I got such a core base man that
they like yeah we got rock with a
personal drug yeah backs for the info
from the from the comedy clubs get your
people here for that's your that's your
fault
and then even a.m. for their joint fo
okay you know what I mean and in in a
way the way I maneuver and I know the
comedy clubs ain't used to you know what
I mean they ain't you sit away the way
I'm moving but you know um if I had it
if I had a million followers right if I
had a million followers a court a
million court flowers right now I'll be
replying five million dollars just on
story just on Sauron yeah you got people
I heard a million dollars that ain't got
no money they making no money off no
online I just hoping to get a brand deal
but if you got a million cuz that
there's certain things you could do you
could do brand deals you could do you
could parlay it into the YouTube videos
you know what I mean you could sell
merch online because you got thinking
but thousand people buy your item every
month and you make $10 every item and
you got thousand people to buy your item
that's $10,000 a month yeah cuz you you
were heavy on the merch game to you push
a lot through that is that been a nice
stream yeah it's been I look at it I
wrote now five ways to make money okay
I wrote down five ways to make money man
I was like re I'm trying to make money
off youtube videos try make money off
brand deals
try to make money off of merch try to
make money off Tori and then sale merch
life Stosh oh that's why so much
slideshow Sailor Mars live at the show
right and so if you right now different
ways to make money and then you say you
know what if I can make $500 on each one
of these now I made $25 that month you
know that's pretty decent
you don't mean you times that by about
12 boom now you into 30 $40,000 a year
range doing a starting salary that's
pretty good if you just aren't make
money as Kamino it but there
yeah so you say okay with next time I
try to double that I make five thousand
I get to $60,000 a year range you know
but then what if it was really good and
went on pop you see them saying not you
now you banking because you always got
to be prepared I say this mom always say
if you woke up tomorrow with a following
of a million people what would you do
you got to be able to answer that don't
don't try to get it no [ __ ] followers
man do not try to get any followers if
you can't answer that question if I woke
up tomorrow with a million followers
what's my next move because I had
already knew my moves five steps ahead
you know and I'm saying like I had
already knew my moves five steps ahead
and so I'm anxious to see I'm gonna come
back another two years so where's this
2018 is 18 right now 2020 we go see you
don't mean oh yeah see what's gonna
happen
so in 2016 you were like I want to build
up my following and they better plan to
work we go on sort yes
so what is it what is it now okay now I
want to build up my following more right
but I want to get a TV show so now I got
to go back to Hollywood you put back in
the machine you know cuz I got on the TV
show and I left
everybody's know why he was on a TV show
I was on the magic just inspired Network
it was cool you know just a learning
process for me but I left LA I was like
you know what you got on it without rep
I gotta know what I rep how did you do
that all right I went in met with some
reps right okay I'll make it quick so I
would've met with some reps right and he
they kind of they kind of played me I
had a folder head a little folder all
the stuff I've been working on what I
thought and all that right and so my man
told me okay check it out first of all I
supposed to meet three times I supposed
to meet me meet the rep three times
right and each time something happen and
he can do it
so one time oh look all the same you
know I'm gonna put his name and it was
just called Sam no Sam can't make today
some happy Oh Sam flight we can make
days some happy and then when he
couldn't make it uh the gay people shut
down Sunset cuz of the uh like they they
they they were um they pretend they
process a lot in your lake so some some
reason gave you to share on the whole
strip there was processing that day and
get on back get on the strip so that was
gonna go to the office that day and so I
was like alright cool and Sony um it was
like can you meet tomorrow
I gotta catch the flight I see know what
I'm gonna readjust my flight I'm gonna
readjust my flight you know what I mean
so I really just the flight I get there
there's something good there like maybe
3 o'clock was like 3 o'clock today at 3
o'clock I'm there earlier I'm there like
255 so I'm sitting out there waiting on
them and I see another guy no from LA
another rep work in the same office so I
go I go I go to him and he's talking to
me right and I'm talking to him and then
when I walk out couldn't be no more than
8 minutes 10 minutes you know me
Sam sitting there on the couch beyond
him right here on his cellphone like
this here on his cellphone he like man
you I was out here where you was at you
know like you know be like well I got a
go man you know me I got a ghost I
probably talked to him like five I mean
he left but my man's that work down the
hall so you know what you got in the
folder let me see never talking about
man's day in my life why another rep
like what you got in the folder let me
see and I showed him what I had in the
folder what not talk to him for a minute
and so he loses the secular producer -
Oh Amy whoa so awesome humbug so
sometimes yeah but and I told him I said
look he told me he say look this was
just what we got for the show I said I'd
do it man but you gotta let me shadow
you he said what you mean I said just
let me let me shadow you me like let me
if you need something I'll run foot you
know whatever you need I got you you
know let me let me show you Slyke all
right that's the bet that's a deal and
so I was on a show but what I got most
important out of that show was I was
able to see I showed work
I was in the room with all the other
peoples out of the room I was here how
okay this this what this guy does
because he the second producer so he's
teaching me everything that this guy
does and so what happens is I become not
first he was just trying to give me as a
actor on the show as a comedian on the
show but then I became his pocketknife
because I could do anything you see what
I'm saying like you need me to read her
to rewrite his script I got that he need
me do this at 12 o'clock cuz the network
getting in his ass he called me in like
I've got try fixes what can we do boom
and he let me he showed me how to work
people if that makes any sense in a good
way like some Jedi mind trick stuff he
never penny regardless of what was going
on at times I'm like damn I probably
panicking right now he never would panic
like my only job is to get it done you
know I mean every cool yeah yeah
for it is one of when the guys on the
show was talking way too fast though he
said he was doing something talking away
too fast and so our executive producer
instead of telling him to cut and do it
over wait he's talking too fast
you tell him to slow down and cut he
won't do that what he say is your call
to the camera guy yo uh cut the camera
tell Mike it's a problem with the audio
we got to redo what he's talking so fast
and so did in the camera the director
said okay it was a problem to audio we
can get it yes they really come in when
you go out there go out there tell Mike
to slow down some let him know he doing
good don't round just slow down but let
him know he doing real good
so cameraman okay he think it's a audio
problem I could go out there tear the
guy onstage but see that's what I saw so
he showed me what it's like to be
executive producer he would teach me how
to get people to move and say your only
job is to get it done it need to be
right your they need to be right uniting
this to be right you a mister get it
done so by any means some go wrong no
problem I figured out you know he he
will all he would never panic because he
would never want the team to be rattled
he showed me what it was like to be a
great coach and I see that's why it was
important to me to do it but he see he
came out to office and just talked to me
when the other guy was in it they just
happened to be the same building it was
the pur coincidence and that's how I end
up getting that first spot on TV but
more than the spot on TV he showed me
what it was like to work the behind the
scenes yes more vital because you got a
look at sometimes you say okay this guy
trying to give me this weapon but he
also got these weapons so I want to know
how to work these weapons so when the
time comes and I'm on my own show or I
got to be exactly executive producer or
I gotta lead people on my own sitcom
I got know how to had that same energy
that he had that if somebody break a
glass on set if somebody fall if
somebody do this you don't panic you
don't rally them you just say oh yeah
you know I mean you control the
situation get it done so it's almost
being self-aware of your weapons but
also aware of other people's weapons and
how they can help you saan saan feels he
got this line where he say it's crazy
because you got to be focused but fully
you gotta be focused on the task at hand
but fully aware of everything that's
going on around you you know I'm saying
once you do that and that's very hard
for comedians because we we got a lot of
perspective because it's all that's what
we do we got
from perspective of the world we always
try to challenge everything but most
comedians lack that self-awareness to
look at themselves they like the
perspective to step outside of their
bodies and look at themselves and high
side is 20/20 so I guarantee you if you
take a comedian they had two million
subscribers on YouTube five years ago he
can look back and say man I should have
did this
mm-hmm when I had to two million
subscribers about not kidding get five
thousand views on the video cuz YouTube
Q me accurately cuz hindsight 20/20 you
know you look back and be like I can see
everything now but when you already got
the perspective so when I got the
follows from Kishore my or the video
store poppin re news set up the tour the
perspective was already there you had in
place I had it in place I was already
collecting emails to go on tour because
the perspective of me saying okay imma
build is following strictly to do this
it was already in place and that's what
you gotta do you gotta have awareness to
step outside and sometimes I'm not
saying you gotta have everything mapped
out you stick without the pivot right
and stuff go calm and you go okay I
gotta do this I gotta do that you're on
I'm saying but you may drop a comedy
album and boom you say okay where I got
this I couldn't do a weapon to come me
I'm gonna be a weapon and you'll come
down pick up steam you say now I got
these amount of people that love my
comedy album these amount of people
stream I coming you have more Shopify
Shopify they all let you see what your
fans are they got these thing called
superfans they'll let you see the person
play just stuck it secondly for 45 days
so you would go hit them cities that
play your stuff a second for 45 days but
to answer your question and bring it all
the way around but the next go-around
what I plan to do is do a sitcom I'm
gonna drop a comedy Apple I'm gonna get
big and big on tour and see what happens
my ultimate goal sell out Madison Square
Garden come on to me go to so I Madison
Square Garden but I look at myself like
a prizefighter
I got a fight right here right here
right here right here and then I could
say boom let's see maybe one day I saw I
only only what 13 14 comedians I've sold
out to garden so I'm trying to put
myself but what happens if I miss then
you got you got a Fox Theater down
downtown you know but we come back in
the next two years I know I probably
chances of me being able to guard in two
years probably ain't saying I can't
almost put in the atmosphere but for the
next two years I want to be trust you at
least have my pilot not get picked up
these be in the room with the people
maybe like we messing with your army so
I'm gonna try to piss that one finish my
the quiches world in pitchy and try to
get it picked up and I'm gonna drop that
comedy Apple and we'll see what I still
be tour and is that what you had in the
folder when you're walking around is
like the pilot no I have money and I had
my next when I was walking around with
them this was 2014
oh is this lame Lance yeah yeah it's
something written up for lame lands yeah
this one I got two Sundays actually
under send this program I'll start right
okay but I never written the scripts
before it right so lame
so okay when I did the Sundance writing
program I don't know I don't know if we
talked about a letter I don't know about
I don't know if I was a you had
mentioned you just mentioned I got in it
but I did it yet you had to just mention
having a script based on lame land right
and it got a Sundance program okay so
the Sundays program which this is a Jim
sue if you want to be a writer you have
to say okay Duke it right that's a
weapon so you say okay we're writing
programs are there Sundays got mad
writing programs for you man hmm that's
free you submit and then guess what they
have you chosen they go fly you out they
go feed you for a week they go put you
up they go sit you in the room for the
writers that can help you not writers do
they just pick but specifically writers
from TV that can help you that's your
type you know I mean ain't put me in a
room with the writer from Louie they put
me in a room with the writer from
blackish the writer from girlfriend you
know sandy blew me in a room with the
writer but they because they they know
take a look at you okay this is kind of
right here it's boom let me put them in
the room somebody that can help and so
that writing tool becomes a weapon you
see what I'm saying so basically I
looked at my assets okay I can't really
write that well but let me learn how to
write so I taught myself how to write
how some well I was just about to break
it down so YouTube and Google is your
best friend when you try to figure out
to write these scripts right it's a
thing called them courage on you to hunt
you can watch as hundreds and thousands
of hours of writers actors comedians
they are interviewing these people
Hollywood the Gaeta violent scenes how
to write a script how to set up a script
you know that mean how to format it
right how to format a pilot written in
multicam how to format in a single cam
so it's all out then it's free for you
but the best thing I did was I paired up
with two of my writing partners Thomas
and Xavier we call them ex excellent
director Thomas the actor write an exit
directing the writer and I was behind
they really helped carry me with the
lane lens I had the idea but they helped
me write notice how you got to write
this I got to write this I got to write
it so we all got a Sunday
together so I can never take full credit
begin the sentence all you know it was
my idea
but they all helped birth that idea was
able to get into a program they helped
us you know and we actually so end up
selling the script to shop and agree you
know to a production company for
shopping agreement got a little change
on for that you're not a nice thing then
you just sold it ain't ax banana say
okay we give you six months when you dis
amount of money for six months we try to
shop to get it picked up and that's how
we did it so they pay you to let them
shop it around and see if they can get
picked up yeah and if they picked up
dated production company see they goal
is to get e they have a list of eight
chose they got they buy to eight shows
for shopping agreement right and then
they pitching them different networks
but they pitch them for the network and
the network pick it up then you go into
a production home brother
so they make the money off the
production that's what they do any
gambling they know we're horses been no
horses right guys all you are and
Hollywood mixes and if somebody reps you
you a horse
mmm-hmm you got look at yourself like a
horse so if I want to go back to
representation right if you go for
representation somebody saw you and say
I think this race horse can win that's
all it is you know more than a racehorse
to agent a manager if you can't run a
you got to go you can't race nobody's
business ain't that personal yeah I've
got a very few times you gonna be best
friends which are your agent of manage
you've got to remember you just a
racehorse man you know what I mean
anything that made me being you know
negative but that's what you so most of
us are the agents and managers in the
companies they Bend on us like right now
you got three yards when you're right
yeah when you're happy but they produce
in a lot of the content so they get the
comedians the writers all in-house to
put the productions all in-house they go
to a network
boom so if I got five cut comedians in
my stable and I know my man need three
writers on the show ain't going to find
three writers I'm gonna see who the the
stable of my comedians that can write
nothing from there you hear them saying
seems like that you keep all house you
build it up
so there is a positive and negative to
representation and like the opportunity
with having representation or it may
almost be it may accelerate that process
so so so opportunity uh like with me I'm
not rep but I don't mind game rep okay
like okay so this is the name right even
if you're not rep okay so if you got to
think if you if you're not rip in DNA
we want to rap you or train what we want
to rap you and they say okay we gonna
put you on this this the sitcom not a
sag minimum right the sag man is what
$26,000 episodes so you know you got a
recurring role for 2016 you go get a
minimum $26,000 so you know now they go
you probably gonna make $8,000 you know
you know like a bust you up much how you
wanna go keep a quarter a quarter from a
quarter from $1 where you go make $5,000
episode they say we go get you 12 so
let's try you go get $60,000 that you
could take home at the end of the year
and you on TV so I get you some leverage
now now you begin to comedy clubs so you
try to take what they give you and use
that as leverage now you say I got
$60,000 like set up a little tour line
and I got a little name you know I built
up a little following from the from the
TV show people like me from the TV show
and from there that's the positive but
if I'm making $100,000 on my own and
then I said all right let me get real
but then they already see how at the
moment I could benefit from what they're
giving me cuz I mean I want no TV show
right now you and I mean you ain't ready
I don't want to be on I want to be a
seed level comedian honor
you got think about it they throw me on
arm so most it comes I'll get counseling
anyway your army so they throw me on a
sitcom and I got like a c-level wrote
right I got a recurring role in me
$26,000 episode they gonna give me ten
episodes but we know I'm only keeping a
quarter that you know which is cool so
you know I'm probably gonna make $80,000
on that right but that may take away
from you making the money on the road no
one could beat or I could be touring I
could be building on my father I could
be doing something else right but now if
I get if they say we want to build a TV
show around you it's all of what you
playing for I know people that get show
after show after show at the show at the
show you don't I mean and that's cool
cuz they ain't playing for that they
ain't playing for the name primitive
your franchise player ain't never owned
you can be Scottie Pippen still get a
max deal everybody on or Safi was gonna
make another episode and hilarious they
all getting a million dollars you know
what I mean like you don't matter who
you are you know to be you could be my
man you know from from Southfield all
the way des to Scofield you know a lot
more than them but even the base for
everybody on friends get a million
dollars I don't let names acts of a to
me knows it was going ridiculous how
much there's have extra episode at the
end of friends so you're looking for
like a tray mom show though
yes so the quiches world I'm really he's
his world and I wrote another one I
wrote like another is kind of like this
it's kind of like a variety show so I
got a few of them I got in pocket
different format and it for four minutes
so that way one day if I'm in the room
with them I won't waste my time in the
room with them I say that's what I got
boom this one I got boom this one I got
basically what I'm trying to do is you
see in Avengers I haven't I know what it
is yo my man with the glove he collect
the altar stone so he was going
different different lands and different
continents collect the harder stones he
got all the stones they have all the
power
okay that's that's that's kind of what
I'm trying to do try to like a harder
stones like we're standing up there
right into the Internet to the tour to
the stage to the merch if I can collect
all the stones you're the same I like
that analogy I can sell out Madison
Square Garden but I gotta collect all
the stones if I don't have all the
stones I can't do it and it seems to be
important that you do it one at a time
it's almost like if you try to do
everything you know doing nothing but if
you focus yeah and put all your energy
into one collector stone yeah collect
that stone and then you you gonna need
to team down understand - whoo yeah I
just I had desi banks on here and his
bit you know he has a multi million
followers and but his big thing was the
team like he stressed the team so like
what were you gonna say like how
important that is in your game - um I
always say this right so you got you got
it you some people get help confused
with the team now a team is people are
designed around you that's working with
you to achieve one goal or to achieve
multiple goals but y'all trying to get
to the same same goal at the end that's
the team now help is what somebody say
y'all come through and help record your
podcast next week I help record your
video it's just help it's not team they
not designed for the end goal they not
definitely and go so I don't ever try to
get help confused with the team now
sometimes you don't have a team around
you you from Idaho you from Jackson
Mississippi you know you ain't from New
York doing from LA you ain't from
Atlanta so I need a lot of people to do
it you to you from a town of 200 people
you know I mean you all you got is a
camera and editing equipment so you
don't have no team you may have your
sister to help you set up the camera
show handle team your animal team
designed for that and so there you got
to get it out the mud until you can get
a team you got to say you know where I'm
gonna take all the bruises in the
punishment
that's the difference between the
Warriors and whatever team LeBrons on
take the Cavaliers and you take the
Warriors of last year the Warriors have
a team hmm they have a team and it's
hard to be a team because they solid
they got a team everybody got a job
dream on got a job Steph Curry got a job
Kevin Durant got a job klay Thompson got
a job over here LeBron just got help
what they always say we gotta burn some
more help
you know the burn needs some more help
cuz he ain't got no team he just they
tryin to now he could still win he still
get there he got he got pretty damn far
with just the help you know to me but
had he had a team head yeah you know my
man's gonna get 18 rebounds tonight we
know my man's over here getting nine
assists tonight you know my man is over
here he could for the 3-ball he go he go
he goes shoot you as strong a strong
seven threes tonight you them saying
yeah he had it he had help or some nice
they helpful some nice they won't help
but go to stay got a whole team worries
got a whole team so it's hard to beat
their whole team so you're gonna aim for
the whole team but sometimes you gotta
get it out the mug to help now do I have
a whole team no at the moment I don't
have a whole team I had to take that
punishment so I'm Abed to a you know
when I did the first tour I'm traveling
through the airport with two boxes of
merch to be you know traveling
exhausting and I just a day at winter
time in Chicago I got two boxes of merch
stacked up I'm hopping in the uber with
two boxes of March I'm ordering to Pat
you know I'm double passenger riding so
I can stack up the hoop or I'm ridding
the car and by blowing let me throw this
in the car he ain't got a group of
people when I do you up see them videos
I shot on tour but you can see me like
doing the show sell them out yeah I
ended all the videos myself you know
what I mean I'll go to the next CD I get
the footage from whoever videotape the
dare you know I ain't got a videographer
with me right now cuz I ain't at that
level where I can afford to just have
one on me so I would get like our
freelance so I mean coming to this city
and be like yo where you shoot this for
a few hundred bucks they say yeah so you
got to edit it I just need you to hit
record on the camera but I got all the
cameras you know I mean I'll show him
how to work the cameras before the show
before the show before I go on stage I'm
sitting there with a video out for
breaking down the shots that I want and
to show before that I'm sitting with the
merch person the table could it's what
you do this what you do if you get swipe
it like this time to go to a website
about his car I should be thinking about
stage thank your producer the executive
producer you get everybody go that goes
back to that you know I'm talking to the
your I go to the show I got a printout a
lid
at the door and give it I got to go to
the hotel lobby print on list everybody
bought tickets give it to the door girl
in alphabetical order so she can just go
down and see how many you know so devil
because I saw the tickets I'll make a
[ __ ] the checks in the bag for the for
the comedy club you know I'm oh so you
do it all through your website I do it
out the byway club work I'll do it all
sometimes I'm a split with the comedy
club but mostly 90% it's all through you
it's all through me and but that now if
I had seen people that could say okay we
go handle the finances we go ahead and
emerge we go ahead and the video guys do
ninja all you gotta do is show up and do
the show you know but I had to where I
had to be LeBron before I get on stage
and so it's gonna be a time let's go
come well all I gotta do is walk into
get on stage that's the team well I got
this girl she does this this person does
this this person does this but right now
I just got help I got my man's may
helping me like all right I help you
this I help with the merch
you know I help I got a lot of help I
got a team yeah but you don't need to
see people think you need a team to win
you need a team to win at the end go but
sometimes you gotta get it out the mud
with the help that you got and it helped
get me anybody it could be anybody
around you but that's when you got to
look at everybody it's the okay lemme
learn is his personal weapon who can
help me yeah I've gone through that and
I had a having a videographer some but
there just it was more stressful than
useful in terms of scheduling and yo can
I get that video I'm trying to release
it tomorrow and like you've had a week
and a half do you want to know why why
because they not they not they Ingo they
don't care about the Ingo like how you
just not you know mean a [ __ ] go I need
to hear this yeah yeah they don't care
about the you say you're trying to get
see if they they lose the team then they
all plant okay you got to think about if
I can make two two thousand three
thousand dollars a show at two hundred
100 people in the venue what happens if
I could put it the housing people in me
I can put a thousand people in up in you
now right the tickets are $25 a ticket
so now we make a twenty five thousand
dollars a night I maybe do that two
nights out of the week so I'm making
pity thousand dollars become able to
make two hundred thousand dollars a
month you know just off tourists so now
my videographer can make six figures
right my beats you can make six figures
so they can all hit the team see the
Ingo if they see the Engel and believe
in it they say he can free us so me
getting him this video is very important
me get enjoy this video on time is very
important because I could see how in the
future is gonna help everybody so maybe
it's happened
making sure that clarity's up front
though as opposed that they can you help
me with this tell them like oh why I
need your help with this what I'm yeah
chichi a part of that be a part of that
but then that's if you want them to be
on the team but if you just want them to
may help some people still help you very
good some people are very good help I
want me to like just do they help you
definitely some people help the hell out
of you yeah yeah you don't I mean and
then that's cool too so you may have to
just get some help and been a good help
him like this is but but still explain
to him this is why Nene because it's a
part of the it's detrimental to the you
know what I'm saying like your piece can
be the piece that that that we that
makes a breaks championship and that's
probably my fault and not making that
clear up front of even like why I
appreciate their services or why I want
to work with them and what I think we
can build together yeah I didn't set
that precedent it was more just
transactional and it happens with me too
I'm at fault for that too okay this is
leadership you gotta be a leader so the
CEO of a company you gotta be a leader
that's what you are this is comedy
business yes when you are a comedian you
already CEO of a company whether you
want it or not I tell people all the
time I say listen the moment so you
baking cakes right you say ah damn need
some tasty cakes I want to run a bakery
I think I can sell these cakes we're not
you running a business you run a
business not you ain't just baking a
cake you run a business just cuz you can
make a cake don't mean you can run a
business sometimes so you got to learn
you got to learn that you say if I want
to sell these cakes you tell jokes you
can go get a regular nine-to-five and
tell jokes for the rest of your life you
can make $7,000 $8,000 or nine to five
and get off work and go down there to
laughing school or everyone is they
still run your room now eight o'clock at
night tell jokes
that's your baking cakes but you said I
won't just bake cakes I want to sell
these cakes you can't you can't run from
the business you want to sell cake you
want to run a bakery you want to run a
bakery but you don't want to run a
business they don't make sense right
does that make sense no yeah you go
right of order operate a bakery but you
but you but you don't want to run a
business you won't get up in the morning
but you run the business guess what you
got you got your chance up every morning
a to him you got get off at 5:00 you
know what your business are you
sometimes you don't get off you got to
work overtime
cuz if somebody got a order to come in
but that's that's what happens when you
run a business you know things happen
who signed up for this you're up at 3
a.m. editing an episode released at 8:00
exactly on Monday morning you say you
know where I ain't get my stuff out like
I'm supposed to let me at least drop
like how you didn't look on last week's
episode of the UH other Park and drop to
let us know all right well I got to
forgive Joe he let us know he leave me
hanging yeah but in the thing with that
was I was waiting on a third party I
know exactly I was oh no I know yeah I
know exactly you ain't on the third
probably to set up your start probably
on the Internet's anyway you you can get
it all going and they told you there's
gonna have it at this time and I'm not
having it this time there being like
four days late he's ninety four days
late and so now throws off your whole
riff and now in the biggest episode you
probably got released this year you said
I can't release it this year even though
you build up the momentum they're
releasing their name and I see what you
do is you say well this is why I need it
because I'm gonna build momentum for
this and petition for this and if you
fall some places wise its detrimental
that you get it to me on time yes even
though you may feel as though I'm just a
small piece of the puzzle but you the
small piece of the puzzle can be to make
a break of the championship you know at
one point can be whether y'all go win
the game or lose the game net one is
this win the game losing so we focus on
every point like the games on a lot it's
that important is that important every
itch is ethics or that I yeah yeah I
appreciate you real recognize real you
CIO somebody didn't do what it was
supposed to do you know that's the boss
of does looking at that's from me
running the company yeah I'm looking at
you and understanding that okay I don't
know what happened and you know what was
happening with me is this is me being up
Friday night at like 1:00 a.m.
making sure my piece is done like you'll
come up on the weekend working all night
to make sure my piece is done and it
still didn't happen and it's all luckily
I like where I'm at right now because
I'm developing the habits that will be
sustainable but it's also a mistake the
stakes are low enough to where the
mistake is not just like death it's like
yeah yeah you get you get you get a
stomach you know I got a fall am i mad
at you you're not exactly but is the
system will perceive but that's why you
got to get it right now
exactly so for the moment comes and you
got to go up against another team
everybody nice mmm everybody nice now
now what you go to now I know just to
even be more ahead of schedule yeah you
know more I had a schedule a way you
don't stumble and I don't rely on you
just relying on other people it's just
unreliable
yeah unless they unless your team is
strong unless it's a team yeah this
brother I know he'll just hell yeah but
it's just help is not reliable man help
is never reliable that's the brunt what
they say 'la Brendan got no help we got
to get him some help no you gotta get
him a team mm-hmm if he had a team if he
had a real team set up where this is
where the every person we don't know
what his teammates do you know they do
they do whatever they want this guy
makes go 20 points this night this guy
make it junior Smith made shoots you six
threes and then tonight he go five games
I should know three you don't know we
don't know cuz he's just help right you
know but we know Steph Curry go shoot a
lot of threes klay Thompson cuz she lied
threes Kevin Durant girl she lied threes
Jerry man with a lot of rebounds curry
go get a lot assist this is just a fact
cuz they are team it's hard to beat a
team and that's what I'm trying to do
with the hot breath of us here is build
up a team and a following can live
actual like engaged hot brethren and
sistren as we call them we out cheer and
actually had a - people ask questions
from the hot breath adverse fur you
tremo know so we had go Mookie go who's
a local Atlanta
alright comedian go Mookie go but um
he's new to the comedy game but he's
super engaged in comedy and also this
podcast and we've been we've been back
and forth he's done my show as well but
he actually asked do you create and he
asked us on Instagram cuz I'll post on
Facebook and Instagram okay when I know
when the guest is gonna be coming on and
he asked when you create skits do you
create them for stand-up as well
somebody's accent minutes the other day
um no always the but when I saw that the
quick answer is no but sometimes I
created sketching blah okay this
scenario can be added to my stand-up
like they're lame Lance sketch I had
back in the day it turned into a script
for a movie
you said I'm saying but didn't lame last
actually it's the longest bit in my
stand-up the bit is like 12 minutes so I
turned the headed to a whole bit
so now we got the I was probably my most
hit viral video and they were my most
followed in viral video and then I
turned into a script episodic script
which got me to Sundance and that's the
longest bit my stand-up so I can go
either way but I don't just go out and
say let me let me let me if I could see
where is used where I can use it then I
use it like that but I don't go out
saying let me let me do it but I'm just
aware I try to be
everything awareness is the number one I
believe weapon you can have first thing
you got to do is be aware man or
yourself and then you get is easy I all
say that's easy but it's less difficult
to maneuver once you aware like okay
this is it this literally is what it is
this is what I got to work it almost
gives you a Y and a reason for the
decision making yeah yeah cuz I'll have
I have a checklist of like ten things so
it's my approach me with a project I
have a checklist of and this is actually
my wife helped me with this but I have a
checklist of ten things and if over half
of those fall in like if let's say you
know I mean I've gotten I got approached
to like play like a slave master in this
show for like Kevin Hart lol Network and
I was just like no no and one of the
things on there's like one do I care
about this project what will it look
like in ten years
does it pay what I think it should like
I have this checklist so I just run it
through that and if it doesn't fall
within over half of them I'm like nah
yeah and that was when I was just like
no I don't care whatever short term gain
I get long term guess what's gonna
happen I told myself this too I said I
mean I'll never again doing a project
cuz you know when you're doing a project
it should go look back and saying man I
shouldn't be doing this you know I'm
never again doing it yeah I've never
again doing I mean you go into this
Danny pay me $5,000 nope ain't selling
myself yeah I'm a I'm a bakery you know
me I'm a million Ginny
Ginny's ice cream was she got like 22
locations not $7 for ice cream school
well I'm booming right now we go to gyms
line out the goddamn door selling ice
cream is delicious
it's delicious right sell it leave now
you say that's Brandon right mm-hmm
that's that's the when I said Jamie came
in your head that's what he immediately
came in your head I did the math on
Jenny's allow she's baking making you
know each of the one his locations
making close to four million dollars
here so she got all these locations she
probably making thirty million dollars
you know ice cream that's crazy you ran
the her numbers something one man all
analytical yeah what I look at cuz I'm a
business honest all okay I look at all
businesses and say oh this is crazy like
how much money making it Wow so I'll try
to look at it I look I see if I stand in
the line
I count how many people in the line I
estimate I know I know at a base they
did getting charged 650 for ice cream
scoop at a base they can't walk out here
without paying 650 so if it's 30 of us
in line and they get to me in 20 minutes
I mean every 20 minutes they're doing 30
people so that means 20 going our three
times so they're doing 90 people every
hour so you're talking a 95 pace of 650
you said I mean we know that just a base
that's the man so you do that for every
hour when you go to Jenny's you see it
is that many people thirty people in
line every time they say okay this is
how much the base rate she's making a
holler now she able to do this at every
location there's how much you're making
but so you do the math like you do the
base and then always cut the base in
half and so you say so let's just cut
the base in half
so worst case scenario it's the worst
case scenario do some once you make it
as a supplies and all that oh yes I'll
just cut everything you're happy
immediately I just cut it all the way
I'm staying in line calculating this
yeah I do think I know numbers in line
man I mean such how you break down your
business you have spreadsheets on your
income and expenses
oh yeah no doubt you do all that before
I even go on the road I know how much I
make I'm gonna say if God is good it's
how much I make god is great if God is
our God it's great to so much I make if
God is good there's so much on me okay
god is nice to me this how much on me
mmm the devil showed up there's not much
on me so you'll calculate also but
you'll do like best case and worst case
for every year.this god is great the
devil the devil working right now that's
not much of me
so I'll just be a funny with that but
yeah so I'll calculate every day
calculate a train to a tea so I know I
know if I fail then y know before I get
there because I said a lot of ticks
myself mm-hmm a everybody you know that
means so I pay everybody myself these go
get more headache but once you get a
team somebody just go work for you to go
I know say work for you to go work with
you let's go make sure everybody get
paid sounds like you're building the
infrastructure so that you can just
start plugging like team and got it you
got a plug and play man yeah so when it
comes on
I learned it from my manager McDonald's
when I worked at McDonald's right uh she
sent everybody home one day everybody
home it was like five or six of us in
there she's like y'all playing go home
mrs. Dickson everybody home right Excel
for me except for me I'm like that she's
a notch right you stay it's only me
right she's saying work the register
I watched misdeed drop the fries cook
the burgers
clean the grill drop the nuggets sweet
she didn't miss a beat
all I had to do is ring the food I
bagged a fool get the drinks ring miss
Dean in Mississippi now she just did the
job of five people I never seen her work
none of them jobs but that's why she the
manager has any moment she could drop
everybody she could drop the whole team
and she nodded run everything herself
don't know don't know one man control
the team I can't see vital left you to
work the register I went back there made
the fool but that's cuz she equipped
with all the sets she got all the stones
on the ring on the gloves she got all
the stones during love so any moment you
know what I mean she like my man's and
avenges he snapped his fingers everybody
disappeared cuz he got all Infinity
stones man and if you could do that then
you run the whole show a lot of
convenience ain't got no affinity so
they got good manager agent sometimes
yeah man is your agent yours they trying
to eat you mean you ain't that great if
you integrate as you think you are
without your manager agent but as
dangerous because they feed you this is
all most important to do it yourself see
you understand what you're hiring other
people to do yeah and also communicate
your expectations
effectively yeah and then you know how
to do it when you get you you know they
can't [ __ ] you cuz you know how to
do it right so now I mean audios I'm not
me tell me nah man I couldn't have pitch
on the camera I went to film school take
the aperture take the f-stop up don't
don't don't take the ISO above 1600 no
mo you did 3200 is grainy that's why
it's grainy take it to 1600 drop the F
star would stay up stop on the camera
2.8 drop it to 2.8 you know I can I can
tell them that you can't you can't
[ __ ] because I I want to film school
you can't you go tell me you know about
know how to do all the job
[ __ ] Medina I can't see the average
person can't tell him that so I can look
at the camera I can look at the footage
you know what he shot it on I got the
footage I used to shoot stuff for other
people I do if a comedian doing some I
say bro can I come to shoot some footage
for you for free Wow
one why I'm doing it for free so when
the man that does mine I could explain
to him how about mine done you sure I'm
saying all these easy shots myself on
you so this is what I want I can show my
man is exactly what I want on tour I
need this shot this shot this shot let
me show you the example I sent them a
list when somebody shoot for me I said
my piece
yes wouldwould click link where they can
look at the videos I mean when examples
of what I want so you'll go out and
shoot exactly what you want as almost
like a blueprint supplier people to do
yeah and then sometimes you know when
you do five or six people like that and
you see the help it's gonna be somebody
that's gonna be a standout then they go
get you everything you asked for but
they just better than everybody
mmm when you start making a million
dollars a year on the road to me is on a
year who you go grab the one that was
the best one go go to stay go get the
best rebounder right the best 3-point
shooter right that's how you got doing
yo dude that's how you got to do it all
right we got one more from the hot
breath of Hurst you are dropping
straight dime I didn't make your top I
didn't make Joel's top 5 podcast list
make the top 5 podcast with me this one
ought to be on there man I was sorry I
went down to Lizzy I'm a real wind ng up
brother but see that's awareness that's
awareness alright how you running it and
some people like I ain't I ain't ain't
worried about what nobody else doing
well you did a cut off video we die oh
yeah I'm glad you saw that see I kept
looking at it okay well we good now keep
a key talk apology pause I got come back
you got an extra better even why you got
a extra battery right you learn right
you learn your lessons right I
understand you have their and then in
the camera to see to realize you don't
have a seat but guess what have you had
a team right the team will have another
cadet another camera real quick pull
that one down swap the battery put it
right back and then BOOM Oh team his
team is great I look at AI look at yo
that's they pity me I blow this is a
great team you know
and he stressed the power of a team and
also you know just that they've now
built into a media company yeah when I
interview him like this one's going
longer than the usual it is going longer
than usual when I interviewed when I
interviewed him ours went longer than
usual so the battery died and like he's
reporting with me to flip it back oh
snap you good you good you know it does
this is sometimes what I'll try right
when I do somebody stuff Joe I'll try
not to override right I try not to take
over their stuff so obviously man am i
doing somebody let me know because I set
up with the light drop the lights make
the camera because I'm so used to doing
anything so right first thing the first
thing you said when you walked in you
like I had cameras do you need anything
yeah yeah yeah case I'm gonna run got
lights in the Crikey's some yeah this is
all me this is the mud right now yeah
just show him what we were saying right
uh-huh
before before the camera right we were
saying I say a lot of comedians to say
any worried about nobody else so when
nobody else doing what naa me
mmm I'll run a business Wendy's know
exactly what McDonald or McDonald's got
a 5 for 5 gets a windes guy for four for
Burger King know exactly what McDonald's
doing so I'm always aware I'm always
aware of what's going on around me and
I'm probably and I ain't trying to be
airing about it I be hard pressed to
find another comedian that's busier than
me then work as long as many long hours
as me but I'm still aware I can listen
to every podcast I try to juice my brain
if I'm working out before missing the
podcast if I'm doing this I'm listening
to an interview you could do multiple
things while you're doing if I'm getting
shipping labels ready
I'm print out shipping labels for my
merch which soon is gonna be somebody
help me do that they're strictly on the
team right I'm listening to everything
I'm shopping on my weapons cuz we gotta
collect wet
we gotta collect the stones I got
collect all if anything oh my god gotta
collect all infini you never know who's
watching man you don't know watching
yeah I'm gonna be watching forever I'm
never gonna stop watch dude imma be if
it went up when I seen to be me and I'll
kamini
because I ain't gonna be in comedy long
I got a few projects imma drop and then
I'm about
uh-huh bow-bow look earlier didn't then
you know the average comedian ya retire
yeah
I got a few projects I'm gonna do and
then once I check them projects out this
time I'm a drop we talked about that two
years from now okay you know well this
this could go into the final one from
hot breath from Robert Joseph another
local comic here in Atlanta who we
actually wrote a a comedy writing book
together called the comics playbook yeah
and he had a question that how do you
transition from stand-up to film so you
remember who came forward up one you
bought a book right my boy my man meet
this guy right here soon as you start
Rhema you know this is an irony right
support everybody uh-huh so I see
somebody selling some I say your job you
got the book sweater yeah you pull up
one you grab one real quick you came to
my classes grad show yeah and a lot of
book I bought a book out to the pavement
yo that's awareness that's awareness of
what's going on around you draw got
comedy but let me see what he got it can
help me interesting what you did help
you write it all out right yeah booth
once you had to the points in there from
the writing exercise the right exercise
I'll let you go through all that man but
a lot of how many comedians just from
there saw you selling that book from you
from your city say let me pull up on
your grabbable
dude not many right there were a few but
not now how close are we
and it's at the time that I bought that
book I mean I probably saw me wait a
handful the pioneering love you pull up
on you where you at you don't know me
that's the awareness you always got to
be aware because they any moment
somebody can trigger a thought at any
moment some can happen so I always say
be aware boy you saying about the book
how do you transition for film that yeah
that's what a Robert Joseph said he
asked how do you transition from
stand-up to film well stand-up is a
different weapon from film so if you you
could be behind it like right now Gemara
j-roc Carmichael's behind the scenes of
film film got different possibilities
but a lot of times comedian stand-ups we
only look at the front of the camera we
say that's to start but you're getting
paid more to EP that then ended my man
just the SAG rules you know sag is
minimal base just on the base of the pay
so he didn't pay more to be behind the
camera you know what I mean and but this
is all what you wonder you may want to
be in front of the camera but you're on
a nope never going tore it from behind a
camera so you may be in front of camera
and you get paid less upfront but then
on the back end you collect all that
money on tour from when you tour so
different ways to look at it but the
transition
you got to work their weapon so you
gotta say well that's a different weapon
from stand up now some people naturally
can do that some people can go for the
stage-two over here and they could be
active but some people can't then you
need to find what you could find you
made me take some acting classes or you
go take some improv classes if you in
Chicago's second city you and there'll a
second City UCB you in New York the same
way when I went to LA first thing I did
was gone UCB classes I said let me go to
UCB and get my chops up on some him on
my improv game on my on my acting game
ok this with the black box to this what
we do this how you and it it it all
helps you it all helps you cuz in in
like how your stand-up gonna help you
acting I think the same weapon but if
you can shoot a rifle it's gonna help me
shoot a handgun yes because you used
today you know you know I mean you're
still shooting something you know I mean
is my eyes go get your we're just go get
better yeah yeah your senses gonna be
more keen so what's going on around you
just from shooting the rifle I'll cut a
handgun ain't it hard you know what I
mean right
it's kind of like a QB playing baseball
like a quarterback most quarterbacks
users can go to baseball you know what I
mean like a lot of quarterbacks go to
pictures you say a lot of whenever you
see some I play baseball I go to
football and you they usually a picture
or a tiny yeah you know it either cordon
still have a picture go to football he
using the QB cuz it's the same skill set
so you're saying sure if you want to be
in film start working the weapons to get
into film they're working the weapons
right so you can be ready yeah you want
to right then you know go to film
courage film courage on YouTube a gated
gym you know watch if I ain't doing that
I'm gonna play let me download to film
courage videos but I like you know
there's some very kids everybody can't
listen to Barry cats podcast oh listen
to Joel briars podcast ya know yeah
everybody can't listen to Barry casters
Barry cats got a um like a muddled like
a mono voice yeah so be a generational
disconnect he's 2 out he's an OG in the
game for sure but now you seen a tall
bear yeah I saw him in a Montreal when I
was up there two years ago he did
binnington's podcast Benton's XM radio
show and he interviewed Barry cats on
there I also saw Barry Katz interview
Howie Mandel for his podcast up there
yeah
and it's like geez yeah berry-berry is
like hee-hee the list of talent he has
rep do is astronomical Marius is
probably one of the most um he don't get
a lot of credit but in comedy he shifted
come mmm
with the people he wrecked the things he
did he shifted you know the people that
he he rep they may not be the people
without without while burying it in him
in um in material no no I must say uh
him to Georgia period him in uh I would
say uh we talking managers my man over
three hours stay back
yeah yeah a day Beck used to talk home
right now you know he's what Barry Katz
was fifteen twenty weeks but even with
Dave Becky and like Kevin Hart he said
they all always had a handshake deal
they never even put anything in writing
a lot lately advantages don't know they
don't sound like contracts no more it is
respected you could drop them at any
moment so it's like good contract for if
they drop me right you good I'm saying
so it's just it's just respect but Kevin
Kevin is what you call and it's my
opinion and somebody can listen it so
Washington say he wrong but Kevin is
what you call a great businessman he's a
great work ethic he got the best agent
and manager I believe that so they all
met each other he's the perfect the
perfect storm the Avengers
he had Avengers right he collected the
Infinity stones right now see see you
got to think now if I'm trying to
collect if any I wouldn't go get that
agent a manager first I'll go to
opposite relics I gotta come a different
direction you see it I gotta use what I
can use with the weapons I got mm-hmm so
you know I'm saying if if ain't got no
ain't got no bazooka ain't got no
long-range no no long-range you know
rightful so I say you know what I'm
gonna do I got some um I got some I got
some camouflage together and I got a
knife someone put his camouflage gear
and I'm gonna take this knife gonna
sneak up on everybody you know Indian
I'm gonna grab there right and I'ma
grabbed a bazooka
you know of it and then obviously I'm
here now I'm here now what y'all gonna
do like it the SAS is the silent
assassin cuz ain't you asked most
comedians ain't ain't on a bite radar
you don't I mean that's the I ain't and
then a me being negative to my sellers
just I know I know I don't know you know
convenient you Chinese if you chose to
my
mentioned I the hottest city Khomeini's
in a game ain't mentioning that you know
what I'm saying but you're gonna be one
of those overnights like where do you
come from you're like now he's been
collecting the stones he's been
collecting the stones you don't even
know until it's too late
I think the dude nail was he died
officer someone adventures I don't not
ghostly good move I understand the
concept whatever his name was they
collected the stones when he popped up
on everybody was shot he went to every
continent popped up on him and took the
stones and he was like he ain't gonna be
able to take all the stones he did
that's why everybody's mad at the
Avengers the movie cuz he took all the
stones any snap his fingers a half the
people died he said y'all thought I was
playing it stream ah yeah I thought I
was playing out the stones man how'd he
do that he got the stones yeah I'm
scared I don't want you to take my
stones build to now I ain't taking
nobody just belongs to me yeah exactly
I'm only taking one blind eye this is
this mr. Kilmer I help anybody either
not need to call me up I help them
immediately like I ain't you ain't one
of the people they be like yo man I
could have toured the whole no man you
know you kind of you kind of just trying
to bargain with him now you asked me
about a door deal I break down the whole
resume no this is you want to export
this what you don't want to ask for it
don't want them comedians that try to
you know if I was reading his book one
time and it was like he who learns
something and doesn't share it dies
inside hmm you know what I mean it's all
looking at they say you when you learn
some you give it away as much as you can
to those that are relative of it being
given to so somebody called me and I
need some help I give it to him
you know that I'm even though I know
what took me hours and hours to get it
why not give it to him they don't hurt
me
she don't hurt me to tell you to do how
much money you should be collecting at
the door they go hurt me at all and
that's what I don't get what people
withhold information yes it's like I'm
willing to give away any insight I have
because you you start to do the work
yeah it's like in check and I read a
book right and it was talking about in
LA and when I was in LA it was his book
and it was talking about this barbecue
place it was over the street from my
house I stayed in Burbank
right there was like a suburb ten
minutes outside of Hollywood so I'm in
Burbank and I noticed this barbecue
place the line will always be out to
like across the street
I'm literally across like it was the
lines outside the barbecue right and he
grilling he just doing P he doing
turkey
you know turkey legs all that and I've
read about it in this book
and he said you know I teach everybody
how to barbecue to come in and work out
the chair by the barbecue I could steal
tail who barbecue what you say even
though they sticking to the script he
said I can tell me exactly how to
barbecue but these years that I got in a
game he said that makes it taste - the
way it tastes
yeah I make it you say even though I can
write down exactly how I make it they
can't quite get it right because this is
years in the game he said that's the
secret so I could teach him everything
but they still not gonna be able to
replicate the sauce the way I can do
your honor me nothing Carlos Miller said
on here okay oh yeah you can have the
they can have the recipe but it's the
chef's it's the shelves yeah it up so
you could tell them whatever mm-hmm
Colby Brack and tell me how to how to
get my 3-pointer right then oh me oh me
oh shoot the call Kobe Steph Curry I
could say you got to go into gym as you
93 93 whoa this is work well I got 93
yeah I'm good I promise I'm gonna just
stay go get a contract and I'm never
wrong with that but you ain't gonna be
Steph Curry
right cuz you any won't want to do what
they want to do that's my favorite part
about teaching a stand-up class is
people get in here they're like oh wait
this is work yeah oh wait you just don't
get up there and talk exactly there's
there's math to this if you ask him if
you ask him I saw Michael Jones college
coach not college coach Bobby Knight he
coached him on the Olympic team mm-hmm
Bobby Knight this ball Jordan was
playing the NBA a second he said Michael
Jordan is the most competitive player
I've ever seen he said get the athletes
he's the most competitive he says most
gifted athlete I have seen he say
singing I only got one of the highest
IQs I ever seen he said he asked the
potential to be the greatest and this is
before he played in the NBA he just but
his Bobby not his seen them all see when
you have seen them all you know you know
when you see it like he got all the
Infinity stones right if he just put the
glove on he could be whatever he desired
to be you said I'm saying so you may
have one person had it's defending stone
is Tiffany stone they could still make
some money but it's gonna be rare that
you got somebody they want to put on all
the stones and say I'm a bee I'm a but
to do that you got to be the most Haiti
you got to realize that at some point
they go and I and I hate to sail like
this
you go be the movie came alright how
many times you watch the community met
[ __ ] you have a heart man yeah yeah you
got the glove mm-hmm he got the glove
but Kevin Hart man he ain't funny
well he got the glove and he sold Idol
football stadium right 80,000 people
think you finds laughing like who gives
the last laugh on that yeah no no well I
can't wait two years to follow up on
this this has been one of our most epic
episode it's definitely a top 5 my man
thank you definitely thought ok that's
why we came to this one you like we're
gonna do double I'm gonna double the in
I didn't mean in double to if I was
gonna be hanging out of here but I guess
nodded and your first interview was dope
too cuz we went into the more the social
media side and the evil we went into
algorithms then and how to generate yo
content so you drunk a lot of gems in
that one too Southside know when just
from a perspective point of view how you
did the first interview with me and then
you see me going through the shows and
do the tour do you think yourself like
damn I remember when my man was talking
about that yeah there's okay I just I'm
always curious about their role yes yeah
okay because the sea is always like like
I was uh I used to box I used to box
right yeah no you familiar with Beyonce
wild he'd had with yeah I know that
bronze bomber bronze bombed come out the
same gym right so I remember when he
worked at Budweiser on the Budweiser
truck and you know he was getting off
work and coming to the gym you know we
rap here at pop coins and we scrapped
enough change to go the go-to business
fighting this fight you know I'm saying
he'd be sitting there talking he by mail
not become champ I'm about he's like
baby blue Maybach
you know I mean I he Mountain baby maybe
that was you know 2009 2010 you know
what I'm saying but Dell was like so
you're not saying that he was saying it
on some when he was in LA he hit me up
like I'm in LA I'm like come to we go go
out to some bars right he in the car
army this right before the fight before
you wanna belt I accidentally riding in
the car right and I won't even drink
when I'm driving cuz I said Brian won't
be no reason no be all don't be no
reason getting accident you break your
arm right there we go so you need a car
right I don't let yo man what do you
feel like knowing you about to be the
heavyweight champ of the world if you
win it next fight he's like I don't know
man
[Music]
so but is that it don't really hit me
yet you said people recognize when I go
out he's there but I don't know you not
to be but just from my perspective
always look at him be like then that's
crazy you know me and I remember I got a
picture of us back in the day right I
posted it
this was like years ago this like 2011 I
said this the next heavyweight champion
of the world and it's the next king of
comedy and y'all may not know it yet and
we trying to be arrogant at some point
we got claim that [ __ ] you know yeah
yeah and so for him next they him to be
heavyweight champion of the world is
like probably 1 in 20 million you know
what I mean the fact that he could
actually make it there and then what
happens if I get the glove when and I
yeah I got the glove and now I'm the
king and I got the glove and he he did
heavyweight champion in the world and we
take a picture so my goal is for us to
me to take the same picture of us
standing the same way cuz he came to my
comedy shows everyone I come so huh and
I would say yo I'm gonna put the date
and I'm gonna say sometimes you got to
be just claim that [ __ ] we've claimed it
my man gotta claim your time dude before
we get out of here is there anything
else you want the world to know yes man
I wanna thank you for making this pie
this is my favorite podcast word yeah it
surpassed my industry standard Barry
Katz podcast why what do you like about
it uh you in this ain't no knock the
Battle of Barry uh but like you like a
more precise version well then you get
right to it
I like Barry you know he stretches it
out so I know that ain't for everybody
everybody can't sit there for three
hours
mmm Barry cats are kind of slow you
happen to speed up speed it up time sue
to get up but I like the podcast man um
you get knowledge you give awareness you
ask the questions you you got a enact
the acts and the questions that I think
make some people uncomfortable to ask
your my ask my finances your my asking
about okay how'd that happen
there's a lot of times you get these you
get comedians they almost want to tell
you what happened but you got a way of
easing it out of them you know that I
appreciate like y'all really know how to
access damn questions man to the point
where it ain't offensive you don't read
right so why'd you do that how did that
happen I said how'd you get in that room
so how do you get an agent so if I were
trying to get an agent and if it was me
you put yourself you gotta weigh it and
that's what
berries the Jedi mind you may you may
flip one day and say man I want to
manage talents
you may go a total nobody and they say
this but you love stand-up though man
yeah Barry Katz was a stand-up was I
didn't know it's all in the comedy club
but Stan that it's like heroin dude I
know that that highs like no i yeah i
you telling me I gotta figure out what
I'm gonna do when I retire you got banks
with Don Rickles said communions don't
retire they died late not yet cuz their
highest is it's crazy
mm-hmm-hmm it's a crazy thing that the
chase is almost like being an athlete
yeah at the high is love like when I
can't like yo when I walked on a stage
and they stand up before I get to the
stage there ain't no filling I tell
people is I said I don't know I said you
could put sex in the fulfilling of
imagine gonna standing over for you get
to the stages it's like right here man
it's like crazy it's like crazy I bet
you ask kobe bryant if he had if it was
his last day on earth he'd rather sit
there with his wife and make love his
wife over here at the play in a game
seven at a tie game seven in triple
overtime with him he in the clutch shot
he gonna say man give me that triple
triple overtime flash shot man she'd be
I should be is they know that hi honey
he gotta get his gonna be the greatest
feeling you probably ever felt very
loved it
yeah so anyway yeah I just I think it's
on the podcast with Mike and I
appreciate this part it's why it ain't
you saying because I'm here it's why I
do it man I I create this for comedians
and just comedy fans to just learn about
the craft and Ali and its heart
oh yeah you know our podcast before like
heaven because sisty every week is so I
work brah
yes yes that's why I started that online
course for podcasting because I was like
yeah oh I get asked podcasting questions
every day so now I have a link I can't
send two people
hey here's you good three years of
podcasting in two hours yeah because
it's all big stories right there
it is were long-wear be honest almost
two hours man this is the longest one
we've 45 maybe 50 minutes it was I
remember I just member I had notes and I
was a little bit more nervous yeah but
now it's like not you got you
you got you figure out the flow got your
sauce right man yeah you don't need your
recipe sheet no more hey you know recipe
she cooking right now man you know I've
been doing this a while keep that you
know what what else always in the
interviews though asking people if
there's anything else they wants the
world to know so is there anything else
you wanted the world to know I'm gonna
collect stones like my man from Avenger
sayin ain't nobody do like I'm coming in
as it is what it is a name me being
arrogant I believe you got speak that
into existence you know I'm sayin I've
been collecting the stones and I work
real hard when I say RER like I'd be
like or some obsessive want some like on
some light this is like I Kobe bribed
like many sickening how much I go to the
gym I guess me man
like you get sick like being around I'm
like nah man people you think I'll be
doing only come on my room and go into
it you know everyone it's weird to me I
come out my room and it's I say - I say
y'all I'm gonna be here 200 people show
up and I do my show and I go back in my
room it almost feel like I ain't do it
everybody this is crazy you know that's
why I believe in you because you're not
afraid of the work ya think we're gonna
do it I appreciate that
and the real recognize real yeah my man
tremo
thanks for being on hot breath again
I'll see you in two years
whoa get the people what they want right
there y'all in two years we'll see what
I look like in two years wow this is the
thumbnail you gotta fill up my bed
nice yeah we see we got thumbnails now
we're on YouTube now
[Music]
I breath